right I never looked back
and simply learn to get ahead Jessica
Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
why are you possible with a course from
a premier University
[Music]
true champion who upskilled to win big
how big a massive hike that transformed
my life upon his change gears pretty
early in the race
but Russian wanted to explore more to
get ahead
simply learned from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time Sr career
transformation
industry experts live
experts difficult
with a well-structured course it felt
like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that
didn't choose a quick fix
you just started data science into the
mix
nithin how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nithin from getting ahead
what an all-rounder de Hoya Knight with
flexible learning you can always make it
right crashing your situation
you too will find your way to get ahead
when you simply learn
simply learn get ahead with simply nut
recording in progress
[Music]
all right
hi folks we'll be starting the session
uh in a few minutes
so please get settled in and would love
to know where are you joining from so I
am Russia Khan I'm your host and I'm
joining from Bangalore India would love
to know and chat uh where are you
joining us from it's always good to
network right these events before we
start so please do introduce yourself I
can see a few email IDs which I can't
recognize the name so for other folks uh
please do mention your name uh while
you're introducing yourself joining from
uh before we start so thank you so much
for joining
foreign
I can see
Rahul has joined from Mumbai I can see
Praveen has joined from Pokhara Nepal
beautiful beautiful and I can see
lakshmana has joined from Hyderabad
welcome
I can see sundarajan has shown from
Chennai I can see I'm Shila from
Maharashtra so uh keep the introductions
coming in would love to know where
you're joining from I am Russia Khan I'm
your host for today's webinar and we are
going to be talking about how you can
learn uh how to deploy a multi-cloud app
and also a bonus we have a IIT
guwahati's program preview also included
in clouds plus devops so uh after we
will be covering that post project demo
okay I can see the introductions is
still coming in so please get settled in
uh before we start the session
also just a quick tip before we start uh
you can put down your questions in the Q
a box uh if you have any questions
please don't put those in the chat you
might miss it uh even during the project
demo which we'll be covering so I would
suggest that you put on your questions
in the Q a box you will just see it see
that right next to your chat box which
is which you're basically messaging
right now so we get a lot of messages on
charts so we might miss those so uh
forgive me forgive us for the heart
okay
okay uh so before we start
uh okay folks have already but started
putting down questions there that's
great uh so I I'll just answer a few
questions before we start as well uh so
basically can we get the recording of
This webinar someone has asked so yes
you'll be getting the recording of This
webinar post webinar over email uh so in
case you want to go through it again uh
you can go through the webinar once
again so I hope that answers your
question you let me know on chat or in
the Q a box I can't see your name
because it's Anonymous
uh okay I can see a question coming in
what is the body Cloud app we'll be
taking those when we do the project demo
I'm pretty sure there'll be an
introduction for that we have a very
interesting session lined up for you
folks and uh we can't wait to start that
okay I think someone has asked again
about the recording so recording will be
getting uh post webinar so don't worry
about that you can go through Advance
again in case you want to go through the
project demo or program or any any
questions in general
I can see Azam has asked the question I
I hope that answers your question and I
can see that Meme from your email uh so
sorry if I'm pronouncing it wrong or a
wrong meme I can see Sanjay has joined
from Kolkata I can see satnam from
Chandigarh so I am Russia Khan I am your
host for today's webinar and
we will be starting the free Cloud
devops Master Class pretty soon uh we're
just waiting for folks to get settled in
before we start
keep the introductions coming in before
we start it's always good to network
write these events right and as you can
see that folks are joining from
different different parts of India and I
can see a few folks have joined from
outside of India as well I can see
Sharma from Dubai so hello hello I can
see Sagar from uttarakhan beautiful
beautiful uh place I can see Calvin from
Philippines I can see Priya from Pune
so let us know on chat where are you
joining from and if possible please put
on your name as well because sometimes
we don't get your name from your email
ID hope you understand
I'm pretty sure you will have a lot of
questions when it comes to the project
demo which should be taken today on
basically how you can deploy a
multi-cloud app and also uh we'll be
covering a program preview of IIT
guwahati's Cloud plus devops program as
well in this master class towards the
end so uh stay tuned for that and
meanwhile I can see folks are still
joining in and uh giving introductions
so that's great
welcome everyone
I'll just put on my introductions as
well for folks who have just joined now
I am joining from Bangalore India would
love to know if any Bangalore buddies
here as well someone joined from
Bangalore
and you can tell us where you are
joining from let's Network a bit right
before we start
okay I can see Gotham has joined from
odisha I can see submit from Delhi so I
think we have gotten a lot of
introductions to keep them coming in
and we'll start the session with few
ground rules uh as I said that you can
put down your questions in the Q a box I
think folks have figured it out because
I can see the questions coming in for
the Q a uh box uh on chart if you put on
your questions the session is long we
might miss it we get a lot of messages
on chat so please forgive us for that in
advance and the session is being
recorded you can expect a follow-up
email with recording link webinar
certificate and bonus software for
attending this session bonus offer for
the program uh which you'll be signing
off for uh which we'll be talking about
more towards the end of the session and
also uh to request a proof of attendance
for this webinar you can enter your full
name in the webinar survey so you'll be
getting that once we end the webinar
there was there'll be a post webinar
survey so make sure to enter your full
name so it will look great on the
certificate for this webinar right so
these are a few ground rules now talking
about the agenda we'll be getting to
know a little bit more about you and
we'll be going through a live project
demo on uh you can how you can learn to
deploy a multi-cloud app uh also you'll
be going through a program introduction
of IIT guhati's Cloud plus devops
program and also enrollment steps of
that program and also there will be a
special duration for the Q a part so uh
thank you so much for the folks who have
joined and given introductions in the
chat so welcome again for everyone
everyone's still joining in I can see
folks are still joining in uh before we
start let's start with a very quick poll
as I said we'll get to know a little bit
more about you so how many years of
experience do you currently have you can
see a quick poll on your screen how many
years of experience do you currently
have before we start the session
so I can see the polls have started
moving in already folks are pretty
active here when it comes to
participation I can see that energy
already from your folks so that's great
I can see introduction still coming in
on chat I can see krisha has showing
from nagpur Maharashtra Aditya from
Hyderabad
from Delhi hitesh from Mumbai Abdul from
Hyderabad hello everyone hello welcome
uh we'll be starting the session I am
Russia Khan your host for today's
webinar and we're just having a quick
poll just to get to know reality better
I'll just keep this Poll for 10 seconds
more for a few of the folks who have not
voted you can see a quick play on your
screen so get familiar with the pole
part so we'll be doing that a little bit
of that in the session so I'll be ending
the poll in five seconds so five four
three two one let me quickly share the
results as well as you can see on your
screen so folks who have joined uh as
like in the maximum amount
so that's great half of the folks who
have joined and uh I can see almost one
third of the folks have are currently
studying and also
I can see some percentage of the folks
have zero theories of experience and few
of them very few of them have three to
five years of experience so that's great
and I can see the introductions are
still coming in I can see perny has
joined from Qatar uh so welcome I hope
I'm pronouncing a name right by the way
please correct me if I'm wrong so this
program is powered by simply learn
World's Online number boot camp uh we
have 13 years of digital skills training
experience and we are very proud that we
have professionally trained over 5
million plus Professionals in over 150
plus countries and we are very proud of
that
welcome to the webinar and we are
looking forward to another project demo
from you would you like to give us your
introduction yes please thank you thank
you Russia thanks for giving the
opportunity yeah so welcome everyone
guys
um nice to have you all here right so uh
my name is Dr purushudani and I am a
Solutions architect technology
Enthusiast consultant and trainer
certified Cloud professional innovator
and educator uh I've done my research my
PhD in resource scheduling in cloud from
vit Vellore
um
and I've I've uh as far as my
certifications are concerned I'm a
Microsoft certified Trader AWS certified
trainer AWS certified Solutions
architect professional which is the top
level certification on eaws in the
architect domain AWS certified Solutions
architect associate AWS certified
practitioner Microsoft Azure certified
architecture as well and a few more
certifications as well guys and um
I've been uh involved in two trainings
with uh simply learn and uh many other
players and of course uh I am uh
delivering training for Caltech USA IIT
programs okay with simply learn and uh
like uh many others that is there uh
then uh I specialize basically into
public Cloud platforms that is AWS Azure
and gcp and of course my area of
Interest also include operating systems
and resource scheduling in cloud and I'm
working as an assistant professor in
information technology department in Sri
ramdev Baba College of engineering and
management nagpur I'm a Google Scholar a
corporate Trader have delivered multiple
corporate trainings in multiple
multinational companies uh in in India
outside of India just to name a few like
TCS capgeminis Mercedes and r d clients
Vodafone UK W Africa etc for AWS and
Azure solution architect level trainings
right then this isn't short about me and
I would be happy to deliver you a demo
on multi-cloud platforms today uh thank
you so much for a great introduction uh
let's go go towards the live project
demo basically how you can develop a
multi-cloud app uh before we start we
have a very quick poll uh so we would
like to understand why exactly are you
attending this project demo webinar
today so you can see a quick pull on
your screen before we start a project
demo
so uh you can see four quick options
here these are multiple choice questions
so you can select multiple options and
submit it as well because there can be
multiple reasons for administ webinar
right so we can see the first one I'm
looking uh to become a cloud computing
plus devops professional uh the second
one I want to learn a new language or a
skill the third one I'm here to
understand if clock Computing plus
democracy is easy to learn I'm and the
last one I'm interested in working on
new projects for my portfolio so you can
just quickly tell us why are your
attendance webinar today this will give
us a better understanding on what
exactly are you looking for when you are
attending the webinars with simply learn
and uh
yeah I think I'll just give five seconds
more uh for for a few of the folks who
have not shared uh I can see a great
participation in terms of all that I can
see most of the folks have already voted
so that's great that's a really good
start guys so I'll just end the poll in
fact
five seconds so five four three two one
let me quickly end the poll and share
the results with you and we can see the
biggest reason why folks are attending
the webinar today is we are looking
forward to become a cloud computing
Endeavor professional so you're in the
right place at the right time I would
say uh you have a we have a lot of
things lined up for you and I can see if
the folks have voted and I want to learn
a new language or skill I interview the
folks I'm here to understand if cloud
computing or devops is easy to learn and
uh we can see if you're the folks have
voted for if I'm interested in working
on new projects for my portfolio you're
at the right place we will be covering
our project demonstration after this uh
so I think you will be getting a little
bit idea about you know what you can do
in our project for your portfolio and
the skills the tools the basically what
career possibility covering that uh post
project as well if you have any
questions for that uh for folks asking
about the webinar certificate uh you
will have to stay till the end of the
webinar in order to get the certificate
and yes there is a webinar certificate
you will be getting for this particular
webinar or any particular webinar with
simply run so now moving on to the uh
project part so the live project demo on
multi-cloud architecture design for
modern applications over to you
uh you're doing mute if you're speaking
just a second sorry uh yeah
so uh yeah thank you right thanks Russia
right so multi-cloud architecture design
for modern applications guys correct so
let's uh just uh understand the concept
A bit first on this and then we'll go
and we'll see the demo on the scene
right then Russian just can we have the
next slide
right okay so understanding multi-cloud
architecture so guys what do you
understand by multi-cloud basically so
see multi-cloud being means when you
want to host your application not just
on one Cloud platform but on
um by using the services on of
multi-cloud platform because guys uh
normally in the organization today is
the era of multi-cloud so you will not
find your organization whether you are
working for X organization or why
organization you will not find your
organization just in one Cloud platform
okay
so it's like uh the point is that your
organization may be using some services
from One Cloud platform and the other
services from other Cloud platform as
well okay so the point is that guys uh
if your organization is let's say using
uh some services from AWS and some
services from Azure well they can do so
why they can do so guys because
um it's like they can find some services
to be better with one Cloud platform
some services to be better with the
other Cloud platform and in fact there
can be multiple considerations like if
it it may be uh as far as the budgets
are concerned so some Services may be
offered to you in a cost effective
manner from One Cloud platform and some
services from the other Cloud platform
and apart from that uh see I mean if
you'll talk about Gartner which is a
research organization those so they rate
AWS as the market leader in the IIs
magic quadrant that is infrastructure
services and Azure as the market leader
in the past base quadrant platform is
Services component so then I mean you
may prefer that let's say some services
like pass-based Services get it from
Azure iesb services from AWS okay so
there can be multiple considerations and
based on that you can actually decide
that your organization can actually
decide that they are going to go with
um
uh one Cloud platform for few services
and the other for the um other Cloud for
the other services so the point is then
um uh then you are you'll end up into
multi-clouds and then there is mechanism
like you can always have communication
among these Cloud platforms and that
when you can communicate well you are
doing it in multi-cloud platform then
correct so the definition of multi-cloud
is multi-cloud refers to the practice of
using more than one cloud service as I
said that either example AWS Azure
Google Cloud to host your various
components of an application now why
multi-cloud matters as I said that
multi-cloud offers redundancy guys
um of course it offers you redundancy
also uh so now if you are if you are
let's say if you are deploying your
website
um on servers of AWS and Azure both so
that is like uh having a redundancy so
you will have your servers not just on
the server of AWS but even on the server
of azure as well so let's say for any
reason if if the server of AWS or goes
down well your website will still be
accessible from the other cloud provider
servers correct so multi-cloud offers
you redundancy so you can keep your data
redundant across the servers of multiple
Cloud platforms and so that will give
you improved performance your data would
be always available your website would
be always accessible then of course cost
optimization would be there
because guys as I said that some
Services can be a cost effective in one
Cloud platform whereas see some others
in another Cloud platform so you can
take the advantage leverage them
different services from different Cloud
platforms and of course it will reduce
the vendor lock-in also because now here
you are dealing with multiple vendors
and you're not just dependent on one
cloud provider okay
so that's there and that's why you
should go with multi-cloud that's where
it matters then benefits of multi-cloud
so of course it it gives you scalability
so you can just host your website on
multiple clouds and you can do it in a
scalable manner
um and then it provides you flexibility
also you are not just limited to One
Cloud Platform One server software Cloud
platform but you have multiple of them
uh then disaster recovery of course guys
um so uh
I mean uh you can have your servers in
different regions in different Cloud
platforms and then even if one of the
region fails uh well uh I'll give you an
example let's say if you are running
your website let's say any website let's
say Amazon zomato any website and you
are running it on on on two servers in
two different region and one region
fails guys so yours your website will
not go down because your website will
still be accessible from another region
correct so you can have geographic
distribution of resources that way
yes so yeah next please
yes so then factors to consider in
multi-cloud design okay so now what
factors you should consider while you
are designing a multi-cloud platform so
uh while you're using multi-cloud
Services okay so application workload
analysis okay so SSD specific needs and
requirements of your application
workloads to determine which Cloud are
best suited for each component of course
you should assess your application guys
it's not like that you will go in
heavier and then you would decide that
okay I am interested in using AWS I'll
go with AWS I'm interested in Azure so
I'll go with a show no it's not like
that you should assess your uh needs
your requirements of your application of
your workloads and then you should
determine that which Cloud will best
suit your requirement okay let's say if
you are interested in only past days
resources then you can assist Azure okay
then because let's say Gartner is saying
that that is the market leader so is
azure going to fulfill my needs what is
the uh what is my budget am I is azure
going to give me those services in that
budget so you should take into
consideration all those things before
deciding that which Cloud platform you
are going to use for which service
then data management and security so
ensure data Integrity confidentiality
and compliance across multiple clouds
correct so you should make sure now it
should not happen that if you are using
multi-clouds so it it is it is not
maintaining your data Integrity or the
confidentiality or compliance
requirement no you have to be very very
sure on that you have to be very clear
on that guys let's say if you are
working for uh an intellectual property
rights kind of a company uh so guys tell
me one good thing or for let's say a
government organization or a defense
organization so if you are working for
such organizations are you really
allowed to move your data outside the
country boundaries
let's say for defense organization or uh
for for for government organization or
intellectual property rights of com kind
of a company so no guys so then in that
case you don't want to move your data
outside the country boundary well if you
do so you would be in problem your
company can help you in Pro can can can
can create problems for you correct so
at the same time guys while you are
using let's say AWS Erasure you have to
make sure that these Cloud providers are
not replicating your data across the
regions uh without your consent they are
not doing it automatically for you
correct so you should make sure that
thing correct when you are using
multi-clouds as well
okay then cost management so Implement
cost monitoring and optimization
optimization strategies to avoid
overrents of course you can always apply
monitoring mechanisms you can always
monitor your resources to make sure that
you are not going outside of uh the
budgets okay so you can set up alarms uh
wherein if you have a budget let's say
on your simple account also you can keep
an alarm wherein you can say Okay
hundred dollars is my threshold if I am
using uh my resources and if they are
charging me more than hundred dollars
give me an alarm give me a alarm on my
website okay so uh based on that you can
actually
um do whatever you are supposed to do
then compliance and governance industry
regulations and internal governance
policies as already told you correct so
that should be adhered to when you are
using multi-cloud platforms you should
make sure that those Cloud platforms are
satisfying your compliance requirements
as well they are not they are not just
replicating your data across the regions
without your consent well that should
not happen
next please
yeah
so that's there
right so then that then components of
multi-cloud platforms okay so how can
you have a multi-cloud platform so it
can be a composition of two public Cloud
platforms correct like AWS Azure
together okay
um are like it can be private Cloud
infrastructure so you can have your
on-premises or privately hosted cloud
services to interact with each other
correct or even uh you can have hybrid
cloud in picture like um you can have
public and private Cloud uh working in
together so that can form your
multi-cloud as well so multi-cloud
doesn't just mean to public Cloud
platform it can be a combination of a
public private Cloud as well so that
forms a hybrid Cloud so that can be a
part of your multi-cloud as well okay
next please
right then
um common multi-cloud architectural
models right so you can have multi-cloud
parallel model multi-cloud distributed
model multi-cloud backup and Recovery
model as well so parallel model means
running different components of your
application on different clouds
concurrently like you're running your
website
on different servers of AWS and Azure
let's say zomato website running on AWS
and Azure together okay so together it
is running
so that is what parallel it is running
on different servers so even if one
server goes down
you don't need to bother there is
another server that is also running your
website okay these are my two website R
for that matter uh if there are multiple
customers and uh there is a lot of
traffic so that can be catered in a very
easy manner from those different servers
okay that can be running in AWS in Azure
together okay so it would be easier to
do that then if you are using it in
distributed model then it will
distribute an application across
multiple clouds to enhance the
availability so of course again you your
application your zomato application will
not run on one server but it would be
distributed on AWS plus Azure servers
plus DCP servers let's say and then it
will give you high availability so if
AWS servers are down the Azure servers
and and and maybe the um gcp servers
will take care of the things for you
okay then uh backup and Recovery model
uh so you can use it in a blue green
deployment kind of thing also well I am
going to do that only today right so in
backup and Recovery model what I'm going
to do basically guys we are going to uh
just have our servers in Azure and AWS
and we are going to deploy let's say our
website on Azure and AWS servers okay
and then we are going to one we are
going to make let's say AWS servers to
be our primary site and Azure servers to
be our secondary site so then the point
would be that you can deploy the same
website on AWS and Azure servers but
then all the users request that request
for that website their request can just
go to AWS servers okay and when the AWS
servers are not working when they are
down then only the Azure servers can be
used for accessing the website okay so
it's like blue green deployment wherein
one uh uh platform servers like AWS
servers would be used uh for for for
your website for serving the website
content to the users and when the AWS
servers are down then only the Azure
server servers would become the primary
site and then they can serve to the
user's request but not till the point
that aw servers are running so that is
something that you can do it in backup
and Recovery model like you can just use
the Azure Service as a backup uh if the
AWS servers are down then only the Azure
servers would uh become active and would
serve the user's request
how would one Cloud platform no other
Cloud platform is down okay so we will
employ a balance a load balancer for
that let's say uh Route 53 uh in AWS or
or or or for that matter Azure traffic
manager in Azure correct so I'm going to
show it to you how that will come to
know correct
okay next please yeah
then of course design best practices so
guys uh uh while you are designing a
multi-cloud so you should have API
standardized standardization uh that is
application program interface
standardization so standardized
communication protocols and apis to
facilitate the integration so you should
have the common API uh that
standardization data interoperability
should be there so ensure that data can
be easily shared and synchronized Across
The Cloud of course that is very
important guys so if you are using
multi-cloud so your multi-cloud should
be able to communicate with each other
correct so data data interoperability
should be there data interoperability
correct I think correct pronunciation
right then uh load balancing and
redundancy of course we'll Implement
load balancing and redundancy for high
availability so we'll make sure that our
servers in AWS and servers in Azure will
get the load from the users with the
help of a load balancer so that it is
balanced and then no server would be
overly loaded and then no server would
be lightly loaded they will be equally
balanced balanced they will be equally
loaded I would say then Disaster
Recovery planning so we'll develop a
robust Disaster Recovery plans and test
them regularly I'll show it to you guys
that I mean if I I'll I'll make sure
that my website is running on AWS
servers and Azure servers and initially
the user's request will just go to AWS
servers and then we will manually shut
down our AWS servers as if they are they
goes down and then we'll see that the
user's request will start going to the
Azure servers then I'll show it to you
okay
fine uh so that's there
next please
okay so uh case study on real world
example of multi-cloud in action so
let's go in let's see this but before
Russia I would like to uh see the uh
architectural diagram can we have that
so that I'll just make them understand
the next slide uh okay uh
no next next after this
okay uh yeah this one okay good fine
thank you so this is the final design
architecture guys so this is what we
plan to do here okay this is what we are
going to do here so what I'm going to
create is I am going to create servers
uh I'm going to create multiple of these
servers in AWS and in Azure so I'm just
going to go and I'm going to create uh
two servers in AWS to VMS in AWS virtual
service and two servers two VMS in Azure
guys
okay and of course when we create these
servers guys we have to do it inside a
virtual Network and the subnet so the
virtual Network and Subnet in AWS is
called as VPC and subnet okay so we can
design our own VPC and subnet but of
course we are not going to do that
because
um well then we'll move uh deviate out
of this topic so we will use the default
VPC and the default Subnet in which we
will create our two servers okay and in
AWS and then in Azure uh that network is
called as v-net okay so in Azure also we
can create our own v-net and subnet but
we'll use the default v-net and default
Subnet in which we will create our
servers in Azure as well that is the vmc
measure so two VMS in AWS two VMS in
Azure okay and then we will make those
VMS to work as web servers because we
are going to deploy our website on those
servers so guys for uh VM to work as a
uh like uh for a server to deploy a
website so if you have if you want to
deploy a website on our server so we
have to make sure that we have installed
the web server functionality on that
server correct so if we want our VMS to
deploy our website so we have to make
sure that those VMS are working as web
servers so we will install the web
server functionality on those VMS let's
say Apache server functionality IIs
server functionality so we'll do that
guys okay and apart from that so we'll
make these VMS to work as web server and
they'll be accepting our internet
traffic HTTP traffic hypertext transfer
protocol traffic so we'll be able to
deploy our website on this we are going
to create load balancers one in AWS one
in Azure okay so let's say in AWS I'll
create an application load balancer
which works on layer number seven that
is the application layer and and in
Azure I'll create a network load
balancer or maybe the Azure load
balancer which works only at four of the
OSI model open systems interconnect
model now I'll not be able to go into
the details of the load balancers the
theory part of it but I'll just show you
the stuff into it and I'll just tell you
in just that a load balancer's task is
to balance the load across your VMS so
that no VM is slightly loaded and no VM
is heavily loaded correct
so the point is in Azure we'll use a
load balance in AWS we'll use a load
balancer and that load balances task
would be to give the users traffic
across the VMS in a load balanced manner
like uh so that no VM is heavily loaded
no VM is slightly loaded and that makes
a lot of sense guys let's say I'll give
you an example let's say when you use
amazon.com so your Amazon website is
running on multiple servers isn't it not
just on one server so when you browse
amazon.co.10 guys uh so basically that
Amazon website is running on multiple
servers so where your request is going
to go so that will be decided by the
load balance and let's say if the load
balancer is forwarding all of the users
traffic for Amazon website to only one
server and there are 100 more servers
which are sitting idle so what will
happen that one server will get heavily
loaded and the others 100 servers are
lightly loaded and that the website's
performance will go down and the website
can crash also correct so that should
not happen so then the load balancers
task is what to balance the load across
the server over so that some users
traffic for Amazon website is going to
server when some users traffic is going
to server to some users traffic is going
to server 3 and so on anyways all those
servers are are running running the
Amazon website so if the user's traffic
is load balanced across these servers
well the users can see the response from
the website Amazon website and can see
the website running faster and that's
how it can improve the performance of
the website guys correct so here the
load balancer also will do the same task
it will balance the user's traffic
across these servers now the point is
guys from where the user traffic will
come the traffic will come from the
internet correct so the user traffic
will actually come from the internet
okay
let the user traffic come from the
internet guys that's not a problem but
then how will you make sure that okay uh
that the user's traffic is going to
there to the Azure servers also and to
the AWS servers also so or to the Azure
load balancer also into the AWS load
balancer also so for that we will make
use of either Route 53 service in AWS or
Azure traffic manager in Azure so let's
say I'll go with Route 53 service in AWS
which is nothing but a DNS service also
plus it can balance the load across
different regions and let me tell you
guys Route 53 has different routing
policies through which it can send the
traffic to your Azure and AWS service
AWS load balancer or these servers so
now we will be using one of the policies
of the Route 53 that is the failover
routing policy I can use weighted
routing policy or other routing policies
are also their geolocation latency based
routing failover routing uh and so on
guys there are multiple policies but
I'll not get into the details of that
because otherwise that would mean like I
am discussing the concepts of Route 53
well I'm here to tell you the demo on
this right so I'll not get into the
details of those policies but let me
tell you just in case if you are using
weighted routing policy so you can
decide so you can use both these sites
in parallel active active mode and you
can you can say Route 53 that okay 50 of
the user's traffic send it to AWS
servers 50 percent of the user's traffic
send it to Azure service so that way
both the sites will work together but
guys if I'm using failover routing well
I can use it for Disaster Recovery
purposes Dr purposes okay now you know
Dr purposes guys so let's say if my AWS
let's say if you have your servers in
multiple regions guys let's say in
multiple regions you have your website
running on multiple servers and God
forbid if there is a natural disaster in
one of the region and the entire region
goes down guys so then also you will
still have access to your website from
another region because the website was
running not just in one region server
but in multiple region servers correct
so if one of the region goes down
well the website will not go down
because the website will still be
accessible from another region guys so
guys that's why they say that people may
die but the but the data won't die but
the website will still be running
correct so in the same way
um what you can do here is like we will
be running our RR uh website on Azure
and AWS maybe in same region or maybe in
different regions and then we'll make
sure that this route
P3 with the failover routing policy it
will just send users traffic all the
users traffic which which would try to
visit our website to just one region
that is the primary region let's say we
make the primary region to be AWS so
Route 53 will send all the users traffic
to AWS region only correct to AWS
servers only and let's say if the AWS
servers goes down okay then what Route
53 will do it will make the secondary
region to be primary with that failover
routing policy and then it will
automatically happen okay with that
failover routing policy and then all the
users traffic which was going to the
primary region will now go to the second
region will now go to the Azure servers
correct so in secondary region you can
have the Azure service correct so that's
how route 53's failover routing policy
will use guys so we will send all the
users traffic that would try to visit
our website to just the primary region
AWS servers only initially and not the
Azure servers which are there in the
secondary region and when the primary
region will go down then all the users
traffic will stop going to primary
region AWS servers but will then start
going to the secondary region that is
the Azure service and and and that's how
I'll show it to you this particular demo
guys and our website
well uh we need to register uh we need
to have a domain name registered with a
domain registrar uh that we can use it
as our website so let's say cloud
cognosente.co.in I have it registered
maybe with good ID guys so I can just
use that and and apart from that Route
53 is a DNS service also in AWS apart
from uh capable of load balancing the
load in different regions with different
routing policy it's also a DNS service
so that also I will use to make sure
um that I am going to provide a name to
my website that is cloud
cognosente.co.in right guys so that's
what I am going to do so uh this is how
we are going to implement it right
Russia so can we just go uh two slides
before
maybe the functional and non-functional
requirements
yeah so the functional requirements of
this particular website would be guys
the user should be able to post the con
content of course if you are using any
website let's say a dynamic website so
the user should be able to host the
content oppose the contents correct uh
with multi-cloud or any application and
should be able to update the contents as
well if they need correct and then the
non-functional requirements maybe have
the next slide
yeah so the non-functional requirements
are guys that it should have high
availability of course uh so of course
we'll achieve that high availability
because we will be having our website
not just in in in in AWS but in Azure
also and apart from that guys may we
have the diagram again please the next
slide yeah so apart from that like uh in
AWS or in Azure we can run our servers
in different availability zones guys
that is in different data centers so
that even if one data center goes down
one availability Zone goes down well it
would mean that one server will go down
but the other server which is running
your website in AWS or in Azure which
still be running your website correct so
that will provide you high availability
so we can just create a servers in
multiple availability zones for high
availability correct so that can satisfy
the non-functional requirement as well
yeah can we have one before slide then
the third one is non-functional
requirement
yeah so uh we should be able to access
our website anytime guys correct of
course yes we want to do that we should
be able to access our website anytime
guys so we can be able to do so we
because we are going to have our website
highly available and uh that's how uh we
can be able to do it and of course we
are planning for Disaster Recovery as I
said with failover routing policy if AWS
server from one region will be down then
the another region Azure servers can
still serve your website content correct
so that's why we'll have high
availability and also and we'll be able
to access our website at any time
fine all good yeah so let me now uh go
and let me just uh show you this demo
guys okay so as I said we will be
creating uh so just see this diagram
once more I'm going to create four
servers guys two in AWS two in Azure and
then I'm going to create two load
balancers one in AWS one in Azure and I
am going to use the Route 53 service
then
um in AWS so first I'm going to go to
AWS and I'm going to create two servers
in AWS along with the load balancer and
then I'm going to go to Azure and then
create two servers in Azure with a load
balancer and then I'm going to go to AWS
and I'm going to use this Route 53
policy guys so shall we go and see this
then yeah so may I just have the screen
so shall I share the screen then right
yeah yeah sure okay you can go ahead and
share thank you
great books uh who have questions
related to the project uh demo you can
put down your questions in the Q a box
so Dr purushotta will try to take as
many questions as possible about the
project path so please do that
right guys so I'm just uh logging into
my uh AWS console first
okay AWS account first and let me just
log in in here
I put the username and password and here
I am in AWS account
[Music]
okay fine so we are here now let's
create the two servers guys so there's a
service in AWS called as ec2 elastic
compute Cloud that helps you to create
these servers in AWS so I'll just go to
ec2
and I'm going to create the servers in
ec2 okay so I'm just going to create
let's say Linux servers in ec2 so I'll
just go to instances and I'll I'll I'll
go and see do this okay
just close this yeah so I'll say launch
instance instance or virtual server or
server in Cloud one in the same thing
okay
so I'll give this VM a name let's say
vm1 or I can just name it let's say AWS
vm1
correct and I can just I'm just creating
it in North Virginia region correct so
that's good enough then I have to select
the operating system for this so let's
say I'll go with uh
Amazon Linux okay and then I'll go with
Amazon Linux 2 Ami is the flavor I can
go with Windows or Linux OS I'm going
with Linux OS Amazon Linux flavor to Ami
okay then are the uh 64-bit OS that is
good enough right 64-bit architecture
sorry and then instance type will Define
the RAM and the CPU capacity for my
virtual machine so let's say I'll go
with uh T2 micro uh well there are
different sizes you can go with t family
M family n there are different families
guys correct and in each family you have
different sizes like in tuft to micro T2
Nano and so on uh TM family are
preferred for general purpose usage
likewise there are the families which
are preferred for different use cases
like machine learning uh use cases and
so on so uh T family in this you will
get a less on the number of CPU and the
ram capacity I'm good with general
purpose usage guys okay so I'll go with
T2 micro which gives me 1V CPU and one
Gib of ram capacity
then keypad uh so see if I want to
connect to this virtual machine I need
to create a key pair I mean I need to uh
create a keypad if I want to connect to
this virtual machine from my laptop
maybe okay uh sorry throughputee then
I'll need a key pair anyways I can
connect directly also but let's create a
key pair so I'll say my KP and today's
date uh let's say
um my KP 27 and 9 23 okay I can give any
name okay I'll just create this
then in the network settings as I said
I'll go with default VPC and default
subnet so that's good enough okay and if
you want to create it in different uh
subnet different availability Zone well
you can choose it from here but just for
the purpose of testing it out I'll just
go with the default VPC and default
subnet and then
um may it be created in any availability
zone I'm not bothered with that
then a security group so I'll just go
with SSH traffic if I want to connect to
this virtual machine from my laptop okay
so basically
um
that I can do security group uh is
nothing but the firewall for a virtual
machine so here I am saying that traffic
I want to allow from which uh protocols
or I want to connect to this virtual
machine from uh where uh like from my
laptop if I want to allow uh connecting
to this virtual machine I'll have to
allow the traffic to come from SSH that
works on Port 22 correct plus HTTP guys
because see I told you I'm going to make
these servers to work as web servers
guys correct so I am going to make these
servers to work as what as what as web
servers guys and if I want to make these
servers to work as web servers well uh
then as I said that if I want to make
these servers to work as web servers
guys so I will have to install the IIs
functionality or Apache functionality on
these servers the web server
functionality plus I will have to allow
the traffic to come on to the servers
from internet so the web traffic comes
on which protocol HTTP protocol
hypertext transfer protocol which well
that works on both 80 correct I'll not
go with https that also allows web
traffic but then https is hypertext
transfer protocol with secure uh so I
don't have a third party certificate so
I'll just go with HTTP that is good
enough
storage this is the hard disk storage
for this virtual machine I am good with
that now I want to make this server to
work as web server as I said that's why
I'm allowing HTTP traffic also from
internet so guys for making this VM to
work as web server since this is a Linux
VM I'll just install the Apache
functionality on this VM so I can just
connect to this VM and install the
Apache functionality but that will take
more time guys so what I'll do is I'll
just uh install the Apache functionality
on this VM with the help of
uh what with the help of a script right
here so I'll just go to Advanced details
and I will give the script here in the
user data guys so I'm just going to get
that script and I'm just going to put it
on this VM that particular script that
will make this VM to work as a web
server correct so I am just going to put
that script here guys okay
um that batch script okay
um
so let me just give that script here
okay I'm just going to give that script
I'll just explain you what is in the
script basically so I'm I'm writing it
in shabank format hash bin Dash then I'm
I'll say yum update y that will update
the Apache server then I'm saying Yum
install HTTP Dy that will install the
Apache server guys then I'll say service
httpd start so that will start the
Apache service then I'll I'll check uh
so I'll I'll see check configuration
check config httpd on so that will check
the configuration whether the Apache
service is running or not I mean if if
my server restarts so the Apache service
should also restart automatically so
that is possible with check httpd on
then I'll go to the default location of
Apache that is CD where slash where
slash HTML okay and then in that I'm
creating index.html page and in that I'm
writing hello uh World okay I'll just
remove this okay so now instead of
writing hello world here I will just
write so guys I can put my complete
website content here in index.html but
just to differentiate here I'll just
create this simple index.html with a
simple
um content here wherein I'm going to
write by what is a hello world I am
from
AWS vm1 okay just to differentiate guys
so when the request would be served from
this AWS VM I the users will see the uh
What uh the users will see the um answer
or the users will see uh what message in
their browsers is hello world I am from
AWS vm1 correct
so when the request will be answered by
this VM This Server correct so that's
why to differentiate it I'm going to
provide different messages for different
servers so here I have Hello World I am
from AWS vm1 okay in index.html so this
is good enough and let's launch This
Server then guys
and then I will create another server in
AWS as well
sorry so let me go to instances again
and let me create another server and
this time I am going to put a different
script okay in this that the message
would be different the uh VM creation
steps would be the same so I'll say AWS
vm2 maybe here
and then I'll go with Amazon Linux
Amazon Linux 2 Ami again
then uh what 64-bit is good enough then
instance type I'll go with T2 micro then
key pair I'll just go with the same
keeper which I have used with my first
VM the network settings I'll just go
with SSH from anywhere and HTTP from
internet the same traffic storage I'll
go with 8GB of storage the same thing
guys in the advanced details I will
again go with that script that will
install the Apache functionality but I'm
going to make a change here guys I'm
saying hello world I am from AWS vm2
okay so now guys when the user's request
will go to vm2 well he will see the
um website response NS browser as seeing
what hello world I am from vm2 and when
its request will go to vm1 so it would
be the response will be hello world I am
from vm1 that is what the response you
will get in his browser okay
fine so let's launch This Server as well
right guys so uh we are having this good
now
um let's go and create a server in AWS
okay so I'm going to sorry let's go and
create a load balancer in AWS so I'm
going to create a load balancer in AWS
and I'm going to go and create a
application load balancer in AWS which
works on layer 7 of The OSI model OSI or
open systems interconnect model has
basically has seven layers okay
um
and that is I remember it as apstndp
okay that is application presentation
session Network session transport
network data link and physical layer so
your uh application load balancer works
on layer 7 that is the application layer
okay that means it can handle HTTP and
https traffic so let me just go and
create a load balancer so that is
available in ec2 itself in elastic load
balancing I'll go and I'll go to load
balancer guys but before I'll go to load
balancer guys I will need a security
group for my load balancer so I am going
to create a security group because see
on your VMS you have allowed traffic uh
on your VMS you have just allowed what
the traffic uh to come from where
on your VMS you have just allowed uh the
traffic to come from HTTP from internet
correct so on your load balance also
you'll have to allow the traffic to come
from internet the web traffic so we'll
say HTTP from anywhere so I'll just
create the security group for that load
balancer first and then I'll go and
create the load balance and I'm going to
supply that Security Group in my load
balancer so I'll go to security groups
and I'll say create a security group and
I'm going to assign it a name let's say
lbsd
okay
I hope guys it's not going fast because
I am going a bit fast here uh because
it's somewhat a lengthy scenario and I
know um you may be having other
assignments also so just to finish it
off maybe in the best possible time we
can so
um I'm going a bit fast okay so lbsd is
the load balancer Security Group I'm
saying and then in the inbound Port
rules uh so here I'll allow traffic to
come from HTTP okay uh hypertext
transfer protocol from there from
anywhere guys anywhere ipv4 okay so HTTP
from anywhere ipv4 okay
correct
okay guys
that's good enough and that is it and
then outbound Port rules anyways all
traffic is allowed to go out by default
that is good enough I don't need to work
with that and I'll say create the
security group
now let's create the load balancer guys
okay so I'll go to load balances
so I'll go to load balances
and I'll I'll just go and create this
load balancer base
so I'll go with application load
balancer as I said you have multiple
types of load balancers here okay so
I'll just go with application load
balancer
and I'll say what create
this load balancer
and then what
I'm going to assign it a name let's say
uh my
uh AWS lb1 that is load balancer one
whatever the name I can assign now of
course it's going to accept traffic from
internet so I'll have it internet facing
if it is going to accept the traffic
from internal resources then it would be
uh I'll select internal load balancer
but here I'll go with internet a load
balancer internet facing ipv4 address it
will work with that's good I will go
with the default VPC and let this load
balancer work in all the availability
zones guys now this is important why
because your VMS can be in different
availability zones guys correct and so
if you want this load balancer to
balance the traffic across those
different VMS which are in different
availability zones in East us so you
should make sure that this load balancer
is working on a different availability
zones here correct I mean in all the
availability zones so you can just
duplicate this tab and you can see where
your VMS are
right guys uh so I mean I can just go to
ec2 and I can just show it to you so if
I go to the instances Maybe
so if I go to the two VMS here so if you
just go to your vm1 you can see its
availability is shown uh well uh or
there itself you could have seen it
so see here my two VMS are in
availability is on 1D only but then they
could have been in different
availability zones or in future you may
deploy more VMS for your website and
then they they can be in different
availability zones as well so for your
for that your load balancer should have
the capability to balance the load to uh
actually balance the load across your
VMS in different availability zones and
that's why I'm just uh having my load
balancers existence in all of the
availability zones so that no matter
where my VM is in East us uh USC is not
Virginia the load balancer should be
able to balance the traffic across those
VMS correct then Security Group
um I will give that Security Group which
I have created guys so I'll just remove
this default Security Group and I'll
give that load balancer Security Group
which allows HTTP traffic from anywhere
fine all good then guys see load
balancer will listen to the traffic okay
fine so your load balancer is a
listening to your traffic guys uh I mean
is accepting the traffic from internet
but then after accepting the traffic
from the internet guys it has to listen
to that traffic isn't it so while it has
to listen to that traffic guys that
should be some listener like we have
ears to listen to the traffic to listen
to the noise and the uh useful
information may be uh something if if if
it is a useful information what I am
telling you you are able to hear it with
your ears correct so in the same way the
load balancer can also listen to the
once it receives the traffic uh the
application load balancer it can listen
it on a listener correct so there has to
be a listener on which the load balancer
will listen to the incoming traffic as
you can see in this diagram correct so
the point is that it will listen to the
traffic and again uh Sensi traffic is
coming on Port 80 HTTP Port so it would
listen it on Port 80 http and then
finally it will give that traffic to
where it will give that traffic to the
VMS to your VMS in the backend pool
correct to these VMS in the Target group
it is called as Target group of your
load balancer where it will give the
give that traffic correct so now guys
tell me one good thing have I added the
VMS in the Target group of the load
balancer the answer is no because I have
not created the target group for my load
balancer as well correct so I need to
create a Target group I need to put
these VMS in the Target group and then
the load balancer will be able to
send the traffic to these VMS in the
Target group so I'll say create a Target
group okay so another tab opens up and
then in that I am going to create a
Target group and see with that Target
group I am going to send the traffic to
my VMS okay so I'll say choose a Target
type as instances and not other Lambda
function or IP addresses or another
application load balancer no it has to
be my VMS where the traffic has to go
through this target group
so I'll give this target group a name
let's say tgp1 Target group one okay and
then of course the VMS will accept the
traffic again on Port 80 HTTP port and
then what health check so that will
check the health of your VMS guys in the
Target group okay so uh let's say out of
the two VMS is if one VM is not running
guys so should the load balancer be
forwarding the traffic to that VM of
course not because otherwise the users
will feel like that website is not
running so if one VM is not working is
down so the load balancer should not
forward the traffic to that VM so that's
why it should check the health of the
VMS okay and that it can check uh
through health check settings so it will
ping the VMS through hell check settings
so here the settings are let's say uh in
every 30 seconds the load balancer will
check the health of the VMS in its
Target group and then um it will wait
for five seconds timeout is five seconds
so it will wait for five seconds to to
get a response from those VMS and if it
gets a response from the VMS then um
it will see to it that if it is getting
the response from the VMS for five times
consecutively then it will declare that
VM is healthy and once that VM is
healthy and if if the load balancer is
not seeing a response from that VM then
it will check that VM twice uh before uh
declaring that VMS unhealthy so if it
doesn't receive the response from that
VM for two times consecutively then it
will declare that VM is unhealthy and
will stop forwarding the traffic to that
VM you can always change these numbers
okay so anyways I'm good with these cell
check settings and you can also specify
a file which it can check or ping on
that VM to check the health of the VMS
okay
fine so uh I'll go with these defaults
guys and tags are optional I'll not
change it I mean I'm not creating that
uh and then I'll just go next then see I
need to register my servers to this
target group isn't it so here are the
servers so just select these servers the
VMS that we have created AWS VM Skies
which are working as web servers anyways
and just say include a spending below so
that they would be included as pending
why because why pending because once
this target group is created then only
and load balancer is created then only
they will be added in your target group
correct so I'll just say create this
target group and these two VMS will be
added to the Target group of your load
balancer
so that's good so amazing presentation
thank you thank you
thanks for the appreciation right so uh
let's go ahead and uh right so uh then
um
then what let's specify the target group
here okay so now you don't see that
Target group correct so you refresh it
and you will see it here now that you
have created it here it is right so you
have specified the target group so all
good guys I don't need to give listeners
text that is optional add-on services
are optional I don't need to do that uh
load balancer tags again are optional
I'm not creating that that's it from my
end for this load balancer guys AWS load
balancer and then I'll create this AWS
load balancer okay
so this is what is created guys so load
balancer with the two VMS on AWS is good
it's done guys and if you will go to
this load balancer if you view this load
balancer well it must be in the process
of getting created once it is created if
you will copy the load balancers DNS
name and if you put it in your browser
well you will see the responses from AWS
VMS the website that is running on AWS
VM will give you the response it will
give you the message hello world I'm
from vm1 AWS vm1 or hello world I'm from
AWS vm2 uh based on whether the request
is going to either vm1 or vm2 of your
AWS VMS correct
just this part we are done with okay so
uh let me just refresh it and see if the
if the load balance is provision I can
give you that link guys you can put it
in your browser and we will see the
response coming from vm1 or vm2 okay
Route 53 will be the final step of
course and before that I'll also go to
uh what the uh Azure also right so while
this load balancer is getting
provisioned in AWS let's go to Azure and
let's create a load balancer and let's
create the servers and the um load
balancer in Azure guys so I'm already
logged into my Azure portal just to make
it fast for you right so here in Azure
like you created the VMS in AWS with a
service called as ec2 in Azure if you
have to create your VMS well you have
the service called as VMS in Azure that
can help you to create VMS in Azure
right so what I'm going to do I've done
this part correct that is the two VMS in
AWS with a load balancer now I'm going
in Azure and creating the two VMS in
azure with the load balancer in Azure
and then I'll come back to AWS and we'll
do the final part of route 53.
what's the Box on the screen which box
uh this box nah I mean so see um
that's not
see this box is multi-cloud high
availability architecture this first box
is for Azure the second box is for AWS
and then connecting them is Route 53
service in AWS correct I think uh
they're talking about there is some dark
gray
C1 yeah yeah that one
yeah
that was mine and yours video okay
anyways I'm sorry I could have just
placed it on my extended script so
that's now gone fine
okay good uh so fine fine
okay I thought that's not visible to you
but that was visible fine okay so now uh
let's go and let's do this stuff on
Azure side okay and uh yeah before I do
that let's see if the load balancer is
created in AWS okay it must be there
if it is created I'll just show you uh
uh the DNA with the DNS name yeah so it
is active now so if I copy the DNS name
of my AWS load balancer guys and if I
give it to you in the chat window well
if I put it on everyone and you can just
put it in your browsers guys and if I
put it in my browser here
so what we can see is we can see the
response coming in in some time so see
Hello World I am from AWS vm2 okay so
that means the load balancer has
forwarded the request to my vm2 here in
AWS correct
so I'm able to see the vm2's home page
now if I just refresh it
if I just refresh it again it is vm2 if
I again refresh it see it as vm1 so now
it is forwarding it to vm1 okay
correct so vm1 VM to see sometimes it is
going to vm1 sometimes to vm2 isn't it
right guys so your load balancer is
working fine and your VMS are also
working fine they are working as web
servers there you have deployed your
website the home page of your website is
saying hello world I am from vm1 and
hello world I'm from AWS vm2 and then
the load balancer sometimes is
forwarding the traffic to vm1 sometimes
to vm2 well that's the task of your load
balancer to balance you load across your
VMS correct great okay so half of half
of a demo is working right so now let's
get to the second half and do the same
thing in Azure okay so I hope it is
clear till this point
so now in Azure let's create the two
virtual machines again so now I'll just
say uh create a virtual machine in Azure
I'll create the first virtual machine
here okay so see in Azure whenever you
are going to create your virtual machine
you have to do it inside a subscription
and a resource Group guys being a
Microsoft certified trainer I have
access to MSD and platform subscription
when you create your account you get a
subscription and Microsoft is going to
charge you on that subscription only so
but then the point is that whenever you
are going to create your resources in
Azure you have to create it inside a
subscription and a resource Group so I'm
going to create a VMware so I have to
put it inside a subscription I'm good
with this mstn platform subscription and
then the resource Group I will create a
new Resource Group maybe let's say I
will just create let's say rg1 Resource
Group or lbr G1 Resource Group that is
load balancer RDU and Resource Group so
Resource Group is a logical container
for holding your sources that's it and
then I'll give my VM a name uh okay so I
can just say AZ vm1 that is azure vm1
now again I can select the region where
I want to create this VM so guys I can
create my VM again in any region let's
say East us or east us2 or any region
guys so your choice you can put it in
any region so let's say I'll go with
East US region you can go in any region
guys that's not a problem okay then uh
just for high availability I as I said
that I can put my VMS in different
availability zones okay so let's say I
put this first VM in availability Zone 1
in East us and then the second VM I'll
put it in availability zone two okay
so let's go with that then I'll just go
with the standard type here I'll not get
into the details of that right now
because of time crunch now image is what
uh so I'll just go with either Linux
machine or Windows machine guys well AWS
provides your support for creating a Mac
OS machine also but uh but that has just
came one year I mean not more than like
it is it has been less than a one year
since AWS has got a support for Mac OS a
virtual machine operating system but
Azure doesn't have support for that so
here you can create Windows or Linux
virtual machine as of till date since we
have created a Linux VM in AWS so let's
go and create a Windows VMware I can
create any VM okay so let's go with
Windows Server 2016 data center okay
um as the operating system for this VM
okay and then what architecture I'll go
with 64-bit architecture here then size
of this VM guys so again like AWS you
have different sizes like there you have
t size and size and so on uh here you
have the D size uh B size and so on guys
so for different use cases you have
different size d size B size is for
general purpose usage normally for your
small medium web servers and database
servers but if you want let's say
um
high performance up to two times
performance boost so you can go with F
series okay and whichever series you go
with guys inside that you will have
different options like D series has
different flavors different options so
let's say I'll go with d2s V3 that gives
me two vcpus and 8gib of ram capacity so
different sizes gives you different CPUs
and RAM capacities I'll go with D2 sv3
which gives me two vcpus and eight Gib
of ram capacity then username and
password guys so I'll just go with uh
the username let's say so now username
and password is important to connect to
your virtual machine so if I want to
connect to my virtual machine well with
this username and password I I can
connect to my virtual machine so
remember the username and password if
you have to connect to your virtual
machine guys okay you can always reset
the password if you don't remember it
but then you should have it to connect
to your virtual machine anyways I'll
just give the username and password guys
and again as far as the inbound Port
rules the security group rules is
concerned guys
the firewall will consist of security
group and then again you have inbound
outbound Port rules outbound Port rules
will allow all traffic to go outside of
this VM inbound Port rules will decide
that which traffic is allowed to get
inside your virtual machine guys so uh
the point is that
um I since I'm creating Windows Virtual
Machine to connect to this with those
virtual machine I'll have to allow the
traffic to come from RDP remote desktop
protocol so I'll say RDP and then if I
want to make this VM to also work as web
server of course I want this VM to work
as web server guys okay so I will have
to allow traffic from which Port HTTP
Port guys so as I told you uh to make
the VM to work as web server I will
install the web server functionality on
the VMS plus I will allow the traffic to
come from internet the web traffic that
will come through HTTP or https Port
https with secure I for that I need the
third party certificate I don't have
that so I'll go with HTTP Port that is
hypertext transfer protocol that works
on Port Ed file just enable traffic from
Port 80 HTTP protocol and of course RDP
if I want to connect to this VM then I
can enable HD RDP Port as well because
this is a Windows VM to connect to this
VM from my laptop maybe I can just
enable RDP traffic remote extra protocol
traffic like for Linux vmu enable SSH
traffic for Windows VM you enable RDP
traffic
good enough then uh this is good enough
guys then I'll go next disc so see uh in
the desk option uh this is the hard disk
for your VM guys so
you can go with any uh like I mean in
the disk you can specify the disk for
your VM so this is the C drive okay uh
OS disk I'll go with the default option
the hard disk for my VM if I want D
drive e Drive other drives I can create
other disk as well and attach it like d
Drive e Drive wherein you can store your
user data well you can store your user
data and see drive also but that is not
good uh because uh tomorrow if you are a
drive gets kind of os gets corrupted so
you can lose on your data if you uh
repair your Os or reinstall your OS so
that's why to put your user data you
should create other drives like the
drive e Drive and so on like you do it
with your laptops okay anyways I'm not
interested in that I'm just good with
the OS disk where in my OS files would
be stored that's good enough and then in
next networking now I need to make sure
one thing I see this VM has to be inside
a virtual Network and a subnet that is
for sure okay I told you so I'll go with
default v-net and subnet but make sure
that if this VM is getting created
VMV net vm1 v-net so the next VM that
I'm going to create should also be
created in the same virtual Network okay
so the next VM that I am going to create
should also be created in the in the in
the same virtual Network guys otherwise
my load balancer will not be able to
balance the traffic across my
um
what do you call it as otherwise my load
balancer will not be able to balance the
traffic across my these two VMS because
the load balancer the network load
balancer uh sorry the Azure load
balancer that I'm going to create has a
has a limitation that it can balance the
traffic across one virtual Network only
correct so uh
my both VMS has to be in the same
virtual Network that's why so az1 vm1 AZ
vm1 v-net is the virtual Network where
my first VM is getting created so this
virtual Network should be the same uh
when I'm going to create my another VM
okay so that has to be in the same
virtual Network
fine
all good and HTTP RDP allowed so that's
good and let's say review and create and
let's create this okay so I'll just say
review and create other options I'm not
interested in so I'll just say review
and create and I'll create this virtual
machine guys
so validation passed and I'll just hit
on create
and sorry Rasha it's taking time but
doing it fast but it's actually a lot
yeah I can I can see the folks still
here so I don't think so we have any
issues
okay so let me tell you I'm doing it
fast but then uh it's a lengthy scenario
actually yeah
so fine uh thank you for allowing me to
do it so let's go ahead and let's create
the second VM and thank you guys for
being here with me right okay so let's
create the second VM then
while that first is getting created okay
uh let's try to create the second VM but
the point is that I would allow that
first VM to get created first why
because I want that same v-net to appear
because in Azure you sometimes have bugs
that same v-net will not be visible to
you while you will create the second VM
sometimes guys
it's the case
okay so I will just try to
maybe go ahead and see to it
once this is created or maybe just a
second mode
uh okay while this is getting created
let's try to create the other VM
if if so guys in Azure there's a bug you
may not see that v-net again I mean uh
that same v-net while creating the other
VM you may not see it ideally you should
be able to see it guys because you are
in the same region so you should see
that venet but sometimes you don't see
it so then the option is you you need to
refresh and uh come back again and then
sometimes you see it okay
my name is this VM has got created so
now I'll create the other VM so I'll
just say create another Azure virtual
machine
um and I will just go in the same
Resource Group maybe and the uh name
I'll say AZ vm2 and then guys in East US
same region but in different
availability zone I'll go with
availability Zone 2
because I uh am interested in providing
High availability to my VMS by creating
them in different availability zones
okay
so first VMI created in availability
Zone one second VM in availability sold
two in in in in in in what
in
[Music]
um
What in in in Azure correct
right guys so uh then what uh data
center I mean same Windows Server 2016
I'll go with for the operating system
same size D2 sv3 same user name and
password that is uh sorry uh I I can
give different username and password
guys so I'll just go with the same
username and password by the way
just for the purpose of remembrance
anyways I don't I don't need this
username and passwords also guys because
I can connect to my VMS and install the
functionality web server functionality
like IIs functionality or I can do it
with the help of a script also I'll do
it with the help of a script guys just
to make it fast because connecting and
then installing would be a slower thing
okay so I'll just go with RDP and HTTP
again here
that's it guys and just I need to make
sure that uh
ignore okay uh that in networking I
should see AZ vm1 V net yeah so you're
good my good we are able to see it here
guys he said vm1 v-net so we are able to
save some time otherwise if I would have
not been able to see it then I would
have refreshed it because of a sureberg
and then again I would have came here
but I'm able to see it so that's good
guys HTTP RDP allowed so just review and
create and create this VM okay so two
VMS I am creating on my azure
what happens if you select more than one
zone no I mean see one VM can only be
created in one availability Zone okay so
ultimately it would be created in one
zone only if you select two zones also
okay Daniel
I think
so if you're pretty sure you want to
have it in easy is it one only give a Z1
otherwise az2 for give a Z2 so now my
second VM is getting created now can you
tell me what should be my next step guys
see I have created the VMS in Azure but
have I installed the web server
functionality on these VMS since these
are the windows VMS so have I installed
the is functionality on these VMS so I
want to install the web server
functionality in the form of IIs web
server okay so let's install the IIs web
server functionality on these VMS guys
so I have two ways of doing it either I
can connect to these two VMS and install
the IIs functionality by going to server
manager but guys let me tell you that
would be a slower way of doing it
correct and I want the things to work
faster here uh okay so uh I'll just go
with what I'll just go with a script to
install the IIs functionality on these
two VMS okay so let's go with the script
and do it guys so let's go to the first
VM
okay and I'll go to the Run command here
and I'll give a Powershell script to
install the web server functionality on
this VM so what I'll do is I'll just go
to run command here guys
and I will just go to run partial script
and I will give that
script here okay so this is my script
and in the script what am I seeing
basically
so I'm saying install Windows feature
name web server include management tools
then I'm going to the default location
of this where it is installed the web
server functionality that is in C init
Pub www root that is where the IIs is
installed okay the default location of
is and there you have the home page
iis.htm guys that is the default home
page so I'm going to replace its content
so I'm going to remove the contents from
iost.htm and I'm going to put my own
content there so I'm saying add content
path is theme CI Network
www.is.htm and what content I want to
add here so I am giving the value as
hello world
from
from let's say Azure hello world from
Azure from NY this variable I'm using
environment where I'm giving the
computer name so it would say hello
world from Azure from AZ vm1 correct so
that's what I'm going to see as the
website's home page correct on This
Server so let's run this script and it
will take some time to run the script
execute the script on the server guys
and while while it is being done can you
share the scripts please sure I am just
putting it in the chat window here okay
this script okay so now while this
script is getting executed guys so don't
refresh or don't close this page because
otherwise the script execution will stop
okay so while this is being done I will
just uh put this I am not going to wait
here for this to execute so I am going
to duplicate this tab and I am going to
run this same script on another server
but then uh the thing is that I'll be
using a
what the different thing here okay so uh
maybe uh I mean I'll be using the
different message so if you are unable
to copy that particular script from the
chat window well I'm giving to you the
file also in the chat window now from
this you can copy it
you can take a screenshot or otherwise I
have given you that file now from there
you can copy paste correct
okay so now I'll go to another VM
I hope you are able to copy paste from
that now so I'll go to another VM vm2
and then
and then what uh I will just go to this
particular uh What uh
run command
and then I'll say run a partial script
and I'll give that script I hope you are
able to copy you can confirm maybe right
uh and here also I'll say Hello World
from what uh azure
I'll say Hello World from Azure from
what
from computer name that is EZ vm2
correct
so hello world from Azure from vm2 okay
so I'll just run this
okay so this script is also getting
executed guys now while this script are
getting executed on my both VMS and
making my VMS to work as web server well
now uh till that time what I'll do is I
will just go and create the load
balancer I'll just try to go and try to
create the load balancer in Azure guys
correct so now while I will try to
so that is the Azure load balancer that
I'll try to create in Azure so one thing
you need to make sure
so one thing uh
I will just show it to you uh
when I'm creating a load balancer in
Azure guys that is an Azure load
balancer
so see uh when you are creating a load
balancer in Azure nuggets so you have to
make sure that you are creating these
four components which are very necessary
if you create these four components you
have created a load balancer measure
that is the front-end IP file load
balancer where the load balancer will
receive the traffic from the internet
correct okay so this front-end IP will
be a public IP address since the load
balancer will receive the traffic from
Route 53 and Route 53 will get it from
the internet okay so this has to be a
public IP address if it would have been
a private IP address then load balancer
would have been able to receive the
traffic from internal resources of azure
not from over the Internet so this
front-end IP will create for our load
balancer then load balancer should also
send the traffic to the VMS the two VMS
so that two VMS we need to add to the
back end pool of the load balancer like
in AWS we added it to the Target group
of our load balancer here speed term is
back in pool where we need to add those
VMS okay and then of course guys the
load balancer should check the health of
those VMS in the backend pool so that if
one VM is not working which is hosting
your same website let's say zomato
website is hosted on these three VMS and
if one VM is not working so the load
balancer should stop sending some users
traffic that it was sending to that VM
and those users traffic it will send to
the other VMS okay so with the help of
help probe it will check the health of
the VMS and we'll make sure that the VMS
which are working which are running it
is sending the traffic to those VMS only
and then with the load balancing rules
you will map all these things together
that is the front-end IP with the back
end tool and the health probes correct
so this is how it works so these four
components the front end IP the back end
pool the load balancing rules and the
help probes if you create them in your
load balancer you are able to create
your load balancer find I'll not go into
the details of that guys correct so
let's go and let's create these four
components and uh let's just create a
load balancer correct so anyways the
script execution has succeeded on your
vm1 and your vm1 is working as a web
server now and uh on vm2 also the script
execution succeeded and you M2 is also
working as a web server now guys so
let's go to the load balancer okay so
I'll just go to load balancers and I
will create the Azure load balancer yeah
so uh Aditya if you are able to download
it well from that downloaded copy you
can copy the uh copy the text fine
so guys let's create the load balancer
and those four components sorry
so those four components that I told you
you need to create those components so
first the resource Group I'll go with
the same Resource Group then the name
for my load balancer I'll say my AZ lb1
Azure load balancer one I can give any
name region East us because my VMS are
in East us now SKU will decide the type
of the load balancer so I'll go with
standard load balancer guys I can go
with basic also but then the problem is
with basic load balancer it cannot
balance the traffic across the VMS in
different availability zones but it is
free of cost but standard load balancer
can balance the traffic across VMS that
are in different availability zones also
and standard load balancer can balance
the traffic across thousands of across
1000 VMS whereas a basic load balancer
can have 100 VMS only in its back-end
pool pool can balance the traffic across
100 VMS only well I'll go with standard
here because I have my two VMS in
different availability zones then type
is of course I'll go with public because
this low this this this load balancer
will get the traffic from internet it
will get it from Route 53 and Route 53
will get it from the internet correct so
public type here I'll go with regional
because my VMS are in same region East
us uh it can I mean with global it it
you can you can you can balance the
traffic across different regions maybe
right okay so I'll go with regional and
then I'll go with next front-end IP
configuration guys so here see I'll
create that front-end IP for my load
balancer see I was saying the front-end
IPL left to create okay so I'll say
create add a front-end IP configuration
I can give any name let's say I'll give
um
pip1
okay as the name and the same in public
IP address I can say create new and I
can give the same name guys okay lbp1
standard is the SK of this load balancer
SKU is top stock keeping unit guys so
it's a like in layman's terms I would
say SKU is a product on sale which has
different shapes and sizes of it
available let's say if we go to market
to buy a particular shirt so we have
particular sizes of it uh like uh or a
t-shirt maybe large extra large and so
on so those are nothing but the SKS so
in Azure also for different Services you
have different flavors like with load
balancer you can create standard load
balance a basic load balancer so those
are the skus uh once you create a load
balance of one SKU type let's say
standard load balancer then you cannot
change its type okay uh fine so that is
also so skus are immutable uh the types
you cannot change right they are not
mutable
so anyways I'll go with standard load
balance I have selected that so return
that is good Microsoft network is good
so I'll just add this okay oh sorry I
didn't edit okay I'll just say lb pip1
I'll say okay and this is added lbp1 and
I'll add this so This adds the front end
IP for my load balancer now the next
component will be what will be the back
end Pool Guys correct so let's add the
back end pool so in back-end pool I'll
add those two VMS correct so I'll create
a back-end pool I'll say I add a
back-end pool I'll give my backend pool
a name let's say be pool one or any name
guys you can give it now of course see I
told you the load balancer Network Azure
load balancer is a network load balancer
it can balance the traffic across one uh
in in one network only so I'll just put
um is it v-net one v-net okay
so I'll just give that here
and then
uh of course it should it should it
should balance the traffic on my VMS
correct so I'll I'll just give the Nick
card of my VMS guys so Nick card is
associated with my VMS so uh and so so
see the load balancer will receive the
traffic on uh I mean will will give the
traffic on your VMS on the Nick card of
your VMS because the Nick card are the
network interface cards that are
associated with your VMS correct so I'll
say add the uh Nick card so here I will
see those two VMS correct so you should
see those two VMS and you will add it
correct so the two VMS are added to the
backend pool of your load balancer so
I'll just say save
okay two VMS added so you have added the
back end pool also now guys next go to
inbound Port rules and here what you'll
do
here you will add the what
see two components you have added
front-end IP back-end pool now the third
component you'll add is load balancing
rules so in the load balancing rules
I'll say add a load balancing Rule and
I'll give it a name let's say
uh lb1
or my lb1 my load balancing rule one I
can give any name guys
and then you see it will map everything
front end IP to backend pool and help
probe everything so front-end IP what it
is so we have uh given it in Frontier IP
configuration that is lbp1 and that is
yet to be created guys so once this load
balancer would be created then that
would be created so lbbi p1s to be
created but I can see it here so I'll
add that here then back end pool again B
pool 1 is yet to be created so once this
load balancer would be created then it
would be created but you'll see it here
so be pool one okay so fine maybe it's
maybe added already correct so because
you don't see to be created so it is
added already so you are specifying it
here then protocol TCP so load balance
so we'll receive the traffic onward Port
80 HTTP port and we'll give it to the
VMS in the backend pool again on Port 80
so back-end Port again Port 80 then
Health probe
so uh help probe have you created the
help probe guys
have you created the help probe you can
specify it here have you created no you
have not so uh you can just create it
from here so I'll just say I'll give my
help Roba name let's say HP one anything
okay and help probe is also check the
health of the VMS on Port 80 because the
VMS are receiving the traffic on Port 80
and in how many seconds it would check
the health of the VMS interval like it's
specify let's say every five seconds so
I'll I can change that number so I just
give went with that number and I said
created Health probe okay so that help
probe got created
um so this is good enough and see you
have you have not specified that help
probe also here correct so this is good
enough guys and I will just save it okay
so help prop created and load balancing
rule also created guys you have
specified your mapped everything here so
you are all good now you create the load
balances so next outbound portals I
don't need tags I don't need I'll just
say review and create and I'll create
this load balancer guys
okay so I'll just create this load
balancer so validation passed and let's
sit on create the load balancer
I'm done from my Azure part guys is it
clear to all of you yeah
so uh is it clear to all of you guys yes
or no
right so while this load balancer is
getting created guys now I am going to
go back to AWS and I'm going to use the
Route 53 service there but before that I
will just go to GoDaddy and
I can just log in with God ID
okay I'm already logged in so that's
good enough right so uh
in GoDaddy guys I'm just going to go
with my domains and I'm going to use a
domain
uh
there it is maybe I'll just go with my
uh domains guys
my products I'll go with okay and then I
have the domain registered there with
the name what cloud
cognosente.co.n see I could have used
freenom.com or any other domain
registrar like big rock or any other but
uh freenom gives you free domains but
now it is not allowing you to register
new domains anyways I have domains
registered there also but uh NS record
propagation may be slower there
sometimes so uh I'll go with God ID and
I'm going to use this domain name that
is cloud cognosente dot Co dot incorrect
so see I have this domain correct that
is cloud cognosente dot Co dot in guys
and I am going to use this domain so
I'll just copy this domain and I'm going
to go to AWS and going to create this uh
Route 53 service with this domain name
correct but before that guys before
doing that let's go to Azure and let's
see uh whether my uh load balances
created so yes and now guys I'll test it
out with Azure also in parts we are
testing it out correct so our AWS part
till load balancer was working fine
so now in Azure also till load balancer
is it working fine or not
so uh can you tell how we can create DNS
in AWS Route 53 itself correct we'll do
that okay DNS in it yeah I'll just show
it to you I'll uh so you want to say how
we can register our domain with Route 53
so you can do it I'll just show it to
you but I will not do that because that
is chargeable and uh yeah so I'll just
show it to you okay
fine uh so so so here uh in Azure load
balancer see I'll just test out the
Azure load balancing part first whether
that is uh working fine for me or not
okay so I'll just go to Azure load
balancer guys and just copy the public
IP of your here you'll get the public IP
address in your Azure load balancer not
the DNS name so I'll just go to see more
I'll see the public IP address of my
load balance and sure guys I can give
you that guys
so here I can put it here and remove the
dot at the uh sorry the name at the end
and then if you copy it here
and if I give it to you and if you put
it in your browsers guys so what you
will see you will see the request going
to one of my VMS see Hello World from
Azure from AZ vm1 and in Azure many a
times it will send to AZ vm1 only and
then very infrequently I mean uh it will
not be very frequent that it will send
it to vm2 immediately see because behind
the scene which algorithm it is using uh
may not be round robin specifically but
now see it goes to vm2 also for me so it
went to vm1 and now it went to vm2 also
correct so my load balancer is working
fine in in Azure as well correct so is
it clear yeah it is sending sometimes
the traffic to my vm1 sometimes to vm2
correct so this is this part is also
good I can just close this now okay so
this part is also working fine guys
correct
now let's go to AWS let's go to Route 53
and let's do the final step there okay
sorry so let's do that uh so I'll just
go to AWS uh where it is yeah and let's
go to Route 53 here guys
okay so I'm done till this part Azure
AWS now I'm going in AWS in route 53.
okay and I'll say uh what hosted zones
and I'll create a hosted Zone
so I'll just say create a hosted Zone
and I'll give my domain name so my
domain name has to be the same which I
have registered with any domain register
and if you have to register a domain
with Route 53 also as someone was asking
me okay so then uh you can go and uh you
can you can go here domain registration
in Route 53 and you can register for a
domain here correct if you have to
register your domain name through Route
53 itself which also you can do okay so
you can just search it here whatever
domain name you want of course if you
say google.com it will not give you
because that is not available correct
that is taken by Google so you can just
search the domain name which you want
and then if it is available it will give
you otherwise you can go with the domain
name that is available and then you can
search and then you can go for it okay
and see it is not supported okay uh
because uh
is not supported here but then if domain
name with uh TLD top level domain is
supported and that is not given to
anyone else then you can get it from
here so from here you can register your
domain this way I'm not registering the
domain with Route 53 I've already
registered with GoDaddy GoDaddy but I'm
using it with Route 53 so in Route 53
I'll go to hosted zones yeah so I hope
that is clear to you I've just shown it
to you right Anushka
yeah so yes so I'll just say create
hosted Zone and then I'll give the
domain name here
okay so this is registered with GoDaddy
so that is good enough guys and this
code.in what is this
guys.com.co.in so these are called as
tlds top level domains and let me tell
you they are deployed across the globe
and are managed by I can Ina is the
authority which manages the these tlds
these top level domains okay in fact in
fact all route dns's are managed by Iana
only
right description is optional I will not
go with that and then I want a public
hosted Zone I want the traffic from
internet correct so I'll go with public
hosted Zone tags are optional I'll just
create this hosted zone right guys so
I'll just create this hosted zone so
this is good enough I have created my
hosted Zone guys all good now see when
you create your hosted Zone you get two
types of records that is the NS record
and the SOA record so what are these
records guys so NS stands for name
server record
NS stands for what NS stands for name
server record guys and uh
that is nothing but a combination of
primary and secondary DNS server records
so SOA is start of authority record okay
so SOA is start off Authority record
okay and it is nothing but a primary DNS
server record so it gives you primary
DNS server record
okay and uh NS is NS is name server
record
which is nothing but a combination of
primary plus secondary DNS server record
primary plus secondary DNS server
records
secondary
DNS
server
records and guys both are responsible
for domain name resolution correct so
both are responsible for domain name
resolution for resolving names to iaps
correct
so now the point is that this uh here
you can I can show you all so see NS so
record consists of this primary DNS
server record ns1309 uh dot AWS DNS
hyphen 35.org and the same record is
present with NS record also that is
ns1309 dot AWS DNS hyphen uh 35.org so
this is the primary DNS server record
plus there are three more records with
NS records here that are the secondary
DNS server records now the point is guys
see we will have to link our Azure sorry
our AWS Route 53 with our GoDaddy this
domain name correct so how we can link
it up guys I'll tell you uh but uh okay
so but then we will have to link it up
for this website to work so we will copy
these NS records from Route 53 and we
will put it in GoDaddy in that
particular records okay so I'll just
copy these NS records one by one and
I'll put it in God ID so where I need to
put it I'll just show it to you so I
copy the first NS record and don't copy
the dot at the end that is afterward
after.com okay so go to your uh Cloud
cognosente domain here I'm going in here
and then
um
inside this domain what I will do is
I'll just go to the domain and I will go
to manage domain manage DNS okay I'll go
where I'll go to manage DNS
and I'll go to name servers guys where
I'll go I'll go to name servers and see
I'll change the name server records here
okay I'll go put that Route 53 name
server records here okay so I'll just
remove these name server records and
I'll put those Route 53 name server
records here okay so I'll just put those
names our records here I'll just remove
these which are already there guys and
I'm going to put the Route 53 name
server records here so I'll put the
first name server record then I'll get
the second name server record from here
I'll copy it from here and I'm going to
paste it here
then I'll get the third name server
record
then I'll get the fourth name server
record base
okay so I've put the four names of our
records and I'll just save it and I have
not copied the dot at the end like after
com after UK okay so I'll say continue
yes I want to change these names our
records edit the name servers so I'm
done it's success your request is in
progress It's still in progress
hopefully we will see this NS records to
be propagated here and then we'll see
our website working but it can take some
time it can take 72 hours also for
propagation but if it is propagated
we'll see the website working with this
name if it is not then we'll not see the
website working with this name right now
but then immediately but later on you'll
see it working but uh hopefully we'll
see it working right away itself okay so
anyways this is how we have copied the
NS records from Route 53 to freenom now
guys see I'll have to give so do you all
agree with me that I'll have to give the
uh load balancers DNS name or the IP
address also here in Route 53 because I
want this Route 53 to balance the load
across my two load balancers of AWS and
Ensure so don't have to give their
addresses here in Route 53 yes I do have
to give it correct so I will create a
record set I'll create two records guys
that is the a record guys and then let
me tell you a record is also called as
host record correct so I'm going to
create a record which is also called as
the host record uh which
and this host record purpose is to
resolve names to IP addresses again so
I'll create a record guys so first I'll
create it for AWS
so I'll say a record and I want this
website to work as Cloud
cognosente.co.in only not like www.com
Cloud cognosis.co.in so I'm not giving
that sub domain name like www but I am
giving the same domain name cloud
cognosente.co.in and a record and then I
want to point it to my load balancer
correct AWS load balancer so I'll say
Lis Lis as yes and then I'll choose the
end point as what
AWS what application or and classic load
balancer correct and then region where
it is in in in North Virginia correct so
I'll just go with us is not Virginia
where my load balancer is guys correct
if it would have been in any other
region I would have been able to select
it from here then the load balancer I
can see that load balancer because I've
already created that and I can give it
here that's it guys and now routing
policy see I told you there are
different routing policies that are
supported so I'll go with which routing
policy guys I want to show you disaster
Dr purpose also disaster and recovery so
I will go with what failover routing
correct or not correct or not so I'll go
with failover and then in failover I'll
choose the failover record type so this
AWS site I want this to be my primary
site or secondary site I want initially
all the user requests to go to AWS site
or Azure site AWS site correct so this
has to be my primary site so I'll say
primary site correct and then this is
all good I'll check ID I don't need to
give Now record ID I will have to give
one so this can be any number I can give
it see when you create records that you
have a routing that have routing policy
other than simple enter a value that
uniquely identifies each record that has
the same name and type for example you
might assign a date timestamp or a
sequential number so I'll just assign a
sequential number let's say one here and
then to the Azure record I'll assign a
number as two okay so this is first
record created now I'll add another
record for Azure okay so I'll say add
another record before I say create
record and here again a record I'll say
Alias I'll not say yes here but I'll
give the load balancer public IP of
azure so I'll get the public IP of my
Azure load and I'll put it here so what
is the public IP of my Azure load
balancer guys if you go to Azure load
balancer see this is the public IP of
your Azure load balancer copy it and
give it here okay
remove the dot name at the end guys okay
and this is the public IP of my Azure
load balancer and TTL is uh 300 seconds
that is good uh fine so that's not a
problem
okay fine so this is good this is fine
enough and that is time to leave field
uh fine so caching how much time it will
cash in your server and then routing so
I'll just go with what failover routing
again correct and here the record type
would be what secondary correct so I'll
say secondary and then record ID I'll
say two
that's it guys okay so is this is this
is this is this setting clear to
everybody this is where the clubs was of
multi uh hosting multiple apps in Azure
and AWS this is how you do it okay so is
it clear to everybody I hope yes
and put a yes in the chat window oh
okay so maybe I'll just I'll just
quickly review it because I saw one no
so see I I said uh what create uh a
record and then I said uh What uh I mean
I I said create an a record and then I
went with a record and then first I
pointed it to my Azure load balance so I
so so I said Alias says yes then I said
to application load balance in Azure
wherein the load balances not Virginia
so I create selected that and I could
see my load balancer there then I went
with routing policy as failover but I
want my AWS side to be my primary site
so I said uh this AWS load balancer to
be primary site and that's it and record
ID I just gave a number one and then I
said create another record wherein I uh
said the value uh sorry when I I just
gave the Azure load balancer IP here
okay so I went to Azure load balancer I
got its public IP address and I supplied
it here and then I said what a routing
policy failover then Azure should be my
secondary site so failover record type
secondary record id2 that's it create
the record set
yeah the similar out 53 Services is
available in Azure with the name Azure
traffic manager okay
right we could have used that also
instead of AWS Route 53 right so now
this is creating guys so records for
cloud
cognosente.co.in were successfully
created guys correct so see you can see
two records two a records here one for
primary site AWS load pointing to AWS
load balancer one for secondary site
that is azure pointing to Azure load
balancer and guys you are all good with
this now
I can give you my domain name cloud
cognosente.co.in and you can just uh put
it in your browsers and let me know if
you are able to see uh the request going
to my AWS servers or not well you may
see it you may not see it as well okay
so uh I'll tell you the reason for that
so you just put it in your browser and
tell me are you seeing the request going
to my uh AWS
VMS yes or no just put it in your
browser and let me know guys quickly
just put cloud
cognosente.co.in in your browser I've
just pasted the link in the chat window
if you put it in your browser are you
seeing uh the website running are you
seeing the page are you seeing the uh
request going to uh AWS vm1 or AWS vm2
not yet because the NS records are yet
to be propagated then okay
to find that is uh but then I will tell
you why at all you may not be able to
see it okay so I can just go to DNS
propagation
and I can just show it to you so if you
go to dnschecker.org and if you put uh
your uh this domain name here
and uh you you go with NS records here
guys
and if you search it here
well you can see what you can see all
these are that's why you're not seeing
it okay so you see all the red crosses
here guys now uh what do you mean by
these red crosses guys
so that means the NS records are yet to
be propagated correct so on the free
Norm server so on the free Norm servers
the NS records are yet to be propagated
guys see in Switzerland only it has been
propagated but not in other locations
okay especially in India so if you are
if you are browsing it from Brazil
Malaysia you'll be able to serve my
website okay but then in Delhi it is
showing now propagated okay so uh
maybe uh you can just see it in some
time
okay so if the NS records are not
propagated in all the locations well it
can pose a problem to access that
particular website but because it can
take up to 72 hours as well for the NS
record for propagation guys okay so uh
it can take that time of course uh and
then uh you can see that uh running as
well after that is done
okay
um
but that that is okay uh because see our
individual websites with the load
balancers were working fine so with this
also it should it should it should
actually run fine guys correct but if
even if it is not running uh well it can
take some time uh to run in okay uh so
but then after that it will start
running guys okay so but then these are
the steps how it is to be done okay
fine uh right so these are the steps how
it is to be done guys just checking out
on my mobile
okay so these are the steps how it is to
be done guys correct so is it is it is
it clear till this point maybe we can
just hold on see it can take up to 72
hours also for the NS record propagation
correct so uh By the time uh maybe uh if
you if if Russia can go through the
other things so uh if till that time if
that gets propagated then you will see
it running if that doesn't get
propagated till that time well then also
it is okay it can take up to 72 hours
it's actually working for them they're
replying on chart okay from Qatar it's
working now propagated okay working now
they are saying okay so for me it's
working uh so maybe are you from the
same location from Dubai it's working
okay so uh DNS are are are are actually
uh working in Dubai so maybe not from
India location right now but from Dubai
from Qatar it's working now propagated
uh okay so from India working in India
also is it so that's great then right
working from Kolkata okay so that is
great if it is working now guys fine um
so that's great so you have it running
then right okay so that is uh good
enough uh the information guys right so
it's it's it's working for you all then
so is it working for all now from either
lens it's not working okay it can take
them some time yes working in Chandigarh
correct so and I told you see you can
see the
evenness records okay I mean um if that
is propagated in your region it can take
up to 72 hours also to to get propagated
in the in the D in the uh GoDaddy
servers in different regions correct so
uh if they are if they are propagated
well you will see them running
um see in us it's not yet propagated but
if they are not propagated in some
regions it is yet to be propagated it
can take up to 72 hours as well or maybe
half an hour or maybe 10 minutes to get
propagated uh So based on that but we
can see uh that in many of the regions
um
uh it is working okay but switching
between AWS VMS okay so uh yeah so it is
working now but it is switching between
AWS VMS only correct so that's what the
point is right so because uh why it will
switch between AWS VMS only
can you tell me the reason
why it will switch between AWS VMS only
guys
because that is the primary site correct
because that is the primary site that
that's why it will switch between AWS
VMS only correct so that's why it was
switched between AWS VMS only correct so
now if I'll shut down my AWS VMS so then
it will switch between Azure VMS also
correct so if I if I'll shut down my AWS
VMS then it will it will start working
in Azure VMS as well
so Russia do you have it working at your
location
I mean uh let me just quickly check it
was not opening for me
I am located in Bangalore India so maybe
let me try in an incognito window yeah
please
why because
okay so maybe Russia uh working in
Portugal so maybe uh if it is fine can
we just give uh to one of our
participants the access to share their
screen so that uh I mean um and then
just I'll get that screen back uh sure
sure uh who would like to share the
screens can you please uh let us know in
chat or raise your hand
I'll just give you the access uh for
folks who would like to share the screen
to anybody's screen where it is working
right from it is working for you please
do let us know I can see Akeem it's
working for Akeem uh John okay I think
Praveen has raised hand okay
can you just give it to Praveen or maybe
anybody team okay I'm just giving it to
talhat I hope I'm pronouncing your name
right I'll just promote you to panelist
and
should be able to
you should be able to share your screen
yeah so can you uh
you can unmute as well uh
yeah so please can you uh just share
your screen and you can unmute yourself
as well right so you use your share
screen option
uh yeah that's it that's okay you can
just share your Mobile screen uh the
screen basically of the website yeah
yeah where you open it for see when
you're sharing your screen you can just
select that particular uh screen of your
mobile and share it with us you can
unmute yourself also if you want uh if
you want to talk
is that everybody should see it that is
one reason and then the other reason is
I'll just shut down the AWS VMS then and
then the request will go to Azure VMS I
think you can sharing it uh we are not
able to see the screen yet drop the
website can you take us there
if you're comfortable you can speak also
that's okay
uh anyone else who's using web maybe we
can just uh raise your hand I can see
who's using web
would like to share and now even if it
is working in Bangalore so Russia will
not be able to access it maybe because
that is cashed in Russia's location uh I
mean on I can see Anusha Anusha would
you be able to share through web I'll
just give you the access uh thank you so
much uh thank you so much for uh
volunteering for it uh let me you can
stop sharing your screen
I'll just make Anusha the panelist
yes please
okay Anusha I've made you the panelists
uh now you should be able to
unmute yourself also and also share your
screen
if you need some guidance you can unmute
and speak feel free
uh yeah sure I can share my screen yeah
yeah just do that
also also Anushka have gotten many uh
many great questions from you in the Q a
box as well so I just noticed
uh Anusha we are not able to see your
screen yeah now we can yes so as we can
see here is Anusha are you seeing hello
world I am from AWS vm2 so request going
to AWS vm2 now when she refreshes it so
it will also go to vm1
yeah I'm just trying
yeah
and just refresh it again
I was actually looking at it like
earlier it was working uh with both VMS
about the inside will go you can refresh
it multiple times or you can just copy
that same yeah now it is yeah yeah so
see Hello World I am from AWS vm1 so
guys I hope with this it is very clear
that you can see the URL Cloud
cognosente.co.in it's going to AWS vm2
and AWS vm1 sometimes to AWS vm2
sometimes to AWS VMS so this is great
this is working fine but it is not going
to Azure VM it is not at all going to
Azure VM why because Azure VMS are my
secondary site so I want that Azure VM
to become my primary site so for that I
will have to either stop the uh Apache
service in on my AWS VMS or I will have
to stop my AWS VMS so then the Azure
site will become my primary site so can
you please stop sharing and then I will
just then again I will give you the
screen okay uh so I'll just or otherwise
I will
um this will stop yeah okay so now guys
I am again sharing my screen and now see
what I'm going to do with I hope you can
see my screen so I'm going to go to AWS
and I am going to shut down these VMS
correct uh so where is it where is it in
AWS I'm going to go to ec2 instances and
I'm going to shut down my ec2 instances
okay and then the traffic will start
going to Azure VMS okay it would take I
mean initially it would say uh
unreachable and then it would go within
a matter of two to three minutes okay so
first I will just stop these two VMS so
I'm just stopping my these two AWS VMS
guys correct so that the traffic that
was going to my AWS side will stop going
to my AWS site because the AWS region it
would take it as it's it's down and then
the secondary uh region uh will become
the primary then okay so I am just
stopping it let let it get stopped okay
so uh as you can see in this diagram the
now primary site will be off and then
secondary side will become primary then
so I am just refreshing it
um just a second guys
yeah so uh now you can see it stopped so
now I request you to share your screen
back
can we have your screen back
yeah thank you so now see it says 503
service temporarily unavailable correct
now you refresh it multiple times and I
mean in a minute or so it will come back
and this time it will go to my Azure VM
yeah Gateway timeout will come up now
why because see I have it's like see you
are working with with with Disaster
Recovery kind of scenarios your one
region has gone down take it like that
so how fast it can switch back to the
another region that is when this timeout
will go out okay so right now it is just
pinging to your primary VMS only primary
site only the secondary site has not
become the primary side till this time
this is the downtime that you are facing
with your website but anyways this
downtime is good enough for few minutes
because see I mean regions don't go down
on an everyday basis and if your region
is going down well you can wait for this
much down this much time this much
downtime is it should be acceptable to
you correct so this much downtime is
acceptable
it will come up okay uh just wait for
two to three minutes and then it will
come up start pinging Azure yeah so now
it has came back so refresh it it will
it will come back for you as well
okay I got it uh shamana Singh okay so
uh
fine fine fine fine shamana is guarded
back uh
uh Anusha is yet to feedback okay so
maybe Anusha you can refresh it again
yeah I keep refreshing
yeah it will come up
it will come up but then it takes time
for you
where are you joining us from
uh from California
okay
it's taking time from California isn't
it from Qatar also it's working and guys
for those who for whom it's now running
uh you would see the request going to
only Azure VMS Now isn't it
uh well it will go to Azure vm1 and then
after many refreshes it can go to the
another Azure VM as well
this is just what I wanted to show and
uh well if it gets visible in your
screen it's good otherwise
you can just get anybody else's screen
but it will show up in your screen but
it's just that it can take some time it
is taking some time
normally anybody else would like to
volunteer for sharing their screen if
it's working for you uh you can you can
do one thing more Anusha you can just
copy that link and just open it in
incognito window
people
it's working now for her okay so you can
see guys yeah hello world from Azure
from ezvm2 if you do multiple refreshes
then only sometime you you do it
multiple times refresh sometimes you
will see the request going to vm1 or you
can just copy it again and put it in
another incognito window and uh freshly
open a new window and of course and then
you you do a multiple refreshes and then
only it will go to vm1 sometimes because
in Azure it strictly doesn't follow that
round robin uh as the algorithm behind
the scenes that's why it's not going
immediately to vm1 after vm2 but then in
some time it will go anyways that is
supposed to go for some users it's
already going right so you can just copy
it once and you can just copy this and
open another incognito window and then
do this multiple times refresh and you
would see it then okay anyways uh this
will go for others it is going to vm1 so
that is it from my end right guys so I
hope you got it right so it's working
fine and then guys this is a very
important scenario you can just apply it
in your real-time environments isn't it
it's it's it's it's dealing with
multi-cloud uh it's dealing with
Disaster Recovery correct so now you can
have how much robust your application
can be working in different regions
failover scenarios so this can be of
absolute importance in your real working
correct that's it Russia from my mind
thank you
uh
uh and also thank you Anusha for helping
out
thank you and other folks as well who
actually wanted to volunteer as well
thank you so much
thank you
thank you well uh so for folks who would
I I knew that you would want to go
through this recording again I think a
few of the folks were asking about it on
chat so uh I'm just sharing so we are
Live on YouTube as well so there's a
YouTube video which will be live as well
apart from the recording link which will
be getting uh post the webinar so I'm
just sharing that link here in case you
want to view it uh later and want to go
through the project demo once again and
now moving on I'll just share my screen
back
okay
now moving on uh what exactly is
stopping you uh from uh becoming a cloud
computing and devops expert uh I just
quickly launched the school uh you can
see a quick pull on your screen this is
a McQ question so you can choose
multiple choices here so we would love
to know what is your biggest concern
here and also thank you so much folks
for staying uh till the end here of the
session we have a question of the
session uh a bit but thank you so much
we would like to address all of your
queries uh and uh we'll just uh go
towards the Q a session pretty pretty
quick so if you have any questions uh I
saw great participation in the chart as
well uh so thank you so much for that uh
now moving on uh to the next part of the
session program preview and please do
tell us like how how is the project then
from you how was it like did you liked
it did you got it
did you find it interesting
I can see it a lot seeing one of the
best winter ever I agree to that I agree
to that
yeah actually your appreciations keeps
me motivated like when I keep on telling
my learners
and because guys that's I mean I'm very
passionate about it okay so I think um I
mean that I I would like to tell here to
uh to good to do good in any any field I
believe on two principles basically
that is the patience and the passion
okay so I think I have both of them in
this field and I have patient to listen
to Learners queries and I'm of course
very passionate about it so we can see
that because uh but basically I don't
ever see like basically mentors you know
going beyond their time limit even the
last time also you went but that was
basically for basically providing them
as much knowledge as possible right
about the demo so we saw that passion
for sure and I think we can see that uh
from the appreciation which is coming in
on chat here as well for you
thank you thank you very much Chris
thanks a lot prasha yeah so yeah okay I
think we have gotten the responses here
on the poll so let me quickly end the
poll and share what is the biggest
concern here when it comes for you to
taking up cloud computing and devops uh
basically certification on becoming
expert in that so again I think we can
see that we have gotten a lot of votes
for I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready uh
and uh I think we have gotten um half of
the votes where I can't find a fully
comprehensive curriculum in a program
and uh the third one my works really
won't allow me in effect for Learning
and if the folks who voted for my final
difficult to learn from predict other
videos uh so thank you so much for
sharing that now moving on uh to the uh
IIT guwahati's professional certificate
program in cloud computing and devops uh
we actually covered uh such interesting
projects and many more like this in this
program uh as you can see uh how Dr
Prashant has passionately covered it and
you know given a you know really put
clear and simple explanation of it and
we have many more projects like that
which I'll be sharing in upcoming slides
uh so in this you get a comprehensive
and Industrial line learning path and as
I said there will be integrated labs and
projects uh for hands-on experience for
folks who are looking for that
experience when they're translated into
this field uh also you will have access
to online virtual classrooms with live
instructional interaction and this
program will be flexible to fit your
schedule with just eight months of
duration and you can just give 10 to 15
uh for hours per week to complete this
certification
the eligibility for this program you
don't have to be from a non-programming
background
and maybe you can have a little bit
knowledge of the basically uh
programming background a high school
diploma or an equivalent uh to at least
eight years of age and you don't have to
have a work experience in this field uh
for basically DMV certification now the
program how basically this program
builds your uh basically relative skills
uh step by step uh
can you take us to this electives
yes sure right
yeah so
um see basically
um
like when you join this program so
you'll have an index induction session
for cloud for cloud computing bootcamp
and then
you'll have AWS Cloud fundamentals okay
uh which will be the first course that
you'll go through then designing
applications and architecture in AWS so
that would be like architecting in AWS
that you will go through
and after that you'll go through Azure
Cloud fundamentals so basically first
fundamentals in AWS then architecture on
AWS then Azure fundamentals then
um of course Implement manage and
monitor on Azure environment so you'll
study about the uh admin Concepts and
maybe some uh administrator Concepts on
the Azure environment and then the
architect Concepts on Azure environment
with designing infrastructure Solutions
on azure
and once you are done with this guys so
these are comprehensive to market leader
Cloud platforms that you will cover that
is azure and AWS then uh you can go with
cloud computing bootcamp Capstone
project so
similar to these projects like one of
them we have just seen it correct
wherein which will use the services of
AWS and assure both and right so that's
how you can go about it and once you've
done do that then you will get the
certification that you are here I mean
you will go for correct the
final certification and of course the
electors are there like Caltech uh cloud
computing boot camp masterclass uh you
can also opt for correct so you will get
the uh
right uh the the the uh the lectures uh
from the Caltech uh you you can attend
that okay uh so that is elective that is
up to you if you want to uh go for that
that's okay
um otherwise uh you can leave it as well
um
right so that is there so there'll be
projectors uh that would be dedicated to
that right
I mean to your course
um right okay sure sure right so yeah
thank you for taking us to the steps I
was on mute uh so we have uh economy
skills basically which open many career
paths as you can see here Cloud
architect Cloud database administrator
Cloud engineer Cloud security engineer
Cloud developer Cloud devops engineer
and uh you basically need up-to-date
skills to be a cloud practitioner as you
can see these many skills uh which you
can take up uh and uh but can you let us
know where someone can start from if
there's a Zillow my rightly where do you
start there are so many skills to take
on right maybe we can give one example
okay yeah just one example I'll give so
you can start with practitioner and guys
uh like if you become a practitioner so
it's like getting the fundamentals of
the cloud let's say AWS or assure and
then you don't have to be master of all
these trades trades uh so you can be a
jack of all uh but but there are many
services okay so
um you can you can start off the uh
first you can start off with AWS in this
and then you can uh have the know of
know how of different services like uh
application migration what are the
services in AWS web services in API
performance testing Auto scaling how you
can do uh so there is an auto scaling
service so which with which you can
automatically scale your VMS up and down
plus identity and access management
wherein you can create the users and
manage them on AWS Cloud platform Cloud
migration and deployment okay so how you
can do migration of your data server
from on-premises to AWS okay with
services are supporting that okay
multi-cloud deployment as we have just
seen it database management
correct uh so which are the database
services like for relational data you
have rdas or non-relational data you
have dynamodb okay for for for graph
databases like Facebook which uses it so
you have Neptune kind of a service in
AWS graph DBS like guys you are friend
to someone someone is friend to someone
else and you get the suggestion that do
you want to friends to be that person to
that person so that uses graph databases
so all those services are there like in
database management for graph databases
for nosql databases like spreadsheet
data for relational databases storage
services like for object-based data you
have S3 bucket for Block based data you
have VBS volumes for file share data you
have EFS storage okay uh then Disaster
Recovery Services cross region
application okay all these you can so
the point is that when you start as a
cloud practitioner you you you get the
know-how of these Services different
Services you you don't have to be very
good in the detail stuff but then
initially you start with the know-how
become a practitioner and then you can
explore it more and go with architect
and admin stuff okay
uh thank you so much for taking us to
that I think we're running out of time
so I'll just quickly take you through
the tools and platforms you will be
learning in this uh program so Amazon
ec2 Amazon dynamodb AWS Lambda Amazon S3
and Azure resource manager and many more
uh tools and platforms you know you'll
be getting to cover in this uh program
uh also the Capstone projects uh I think
uh this project being one of the
industry musics which we have basically
done a demo for and but Capstone project
also adds uh basically to the resume
when you basically are getting job ready
you want to showcase to your future
employers that you have worked on some
kind of Real World Experience Project
which can Showcase in your portfolio and
as I said the industry-based hands and
projects for your portfolio all as well
we'll be covering this program I think
uh we have covered uh the deployment of
multi-cloud app today uh and also we
have covered the Azure and ews
connection architecture through VPC uh
as well and we'll be covering the the
third one as well an upcoming session
next month so we will basically uh
covering all these project demos and
also you'll get access to all these
projects to our to your portfolio
through this program so that is how
interesting it is and uh we have global
leaders and program advisors Dr God of
Trivedi being one of the global leaders
uh from triple uh IIT guwahati uh who
basically make sure that we are
delivering as per the standards uh from
Simply love uh when it comes to the
course uh you get job as a Services by
Talent Inc as well uh in this you get
access to the premium resume resume
and a resume review and rewrite service
and also a one-on-one interview Service
as well so uh please let us know uh your
interest towards the enrollment into the
professional certificate uh cloud
computing plus devops uh program uh by
IIT guhati you can see a quick pull on
your screen you can see uh two week
options there yes and no please let us
know would you like to enjoy into the
program of professional certificate
program of cloud computing plus devops
by IIT kohari I can see the interests
already coming towards the enrollment so
that's great I'll keep up the poll for
15 seconds more for a few of the folks
who have not voted before we basically
go towards the end of the session and
also share the enrollment steps in the
program fee and structure cohort all
these things about the program
so quickly go and vote towards the poll
which you see on your screen right now
uh would you like to enroll into the
program uh you can see uh two quick
options there
I'm seeing really great interest towards
the enrollment so that's great and also
we have gotten really good participation
even though we have action with the
session uh from from the audience who
have joined us here so thank you so much
for that thank you for having so much
patience and also I can see that
Curiosity and passion into words
learning the cloud computing and devops
uh program as well you know uh through
the project demo itself so we will be
covering these project demos uh during
other webinars as well and also a
complete project for a portfolio a
caption one also will be covered in this
program so that's pretty great uh let me
just quickly uh check okay I can see
most of the folks have already shared
their interest uh I can see a lot of
interest towards enrollment that's great
so I'll just end this poll in 10 seconds
so few of the folks who have not voted
please go quickly vote
I'll be sharing that I'll be sharing the
question I can't get your name from your
email ID please let me know your name uh
so I I think I'll just end the pool in
five seconds because I can see most of
the folks have already voted so five
four three two one let me in the poll
okay thank you so much moving on uh to
the enrollment steps uh so you just need
to follow three simple steps for
enrollment all you need to do is you
need to submit an application apply at
ask it that's simple.net uh based on
that your application will be going for
review and you'll be getting admissions
call uh from a simply learned consensus
based on the application review the
photography enrollment schedule for this
one is one lakh 24 999 including taxes
uh we have financing options available
as as well as low as four thousand two
hundred fifty four uh rupees per month
uh for full joining from different
countries you can go and check out about
the program uh in the website I'll be
sharing that link on the chat to know
basically what is the fee for the
program in your country and uh the
cohort for this one uh is on 3rd of
October the induction and the classes
will be starting on 7th of October uh if
you have any questions you can reach out
to us at ask us at simplyon.net I'll be
sharing that email in the chat as well
also just to let you know we have very
limited seats per cover so we only take
25 to 30 Volkswagen in order to make
sure that you are giving all the
attention that is required uh you know
and getting all the attention in terms
of uh when you're pursuing the course
and also uh for folks who have already
shared interest towards enrollment uh I
would recommend for us to let know that
when do you plan to enroll so you can
see a quick call on your screen so when
do you plan to enroll so this will give
us a better understanding you know when
do we need to reach out to you for the
enrollment and also you will be getting
a bonus offer for attending this webinar
so do not miss out on that even if
you're planning to enroll maybe within
six months or more than six months from
the launch you can choose those options
as well and folks who are joining to uh
basically planning to join immediately
you can select the first option uh and
uh within three months if you're
planning if the second option and as I
said key if you basically are still
thinking about it but you are interested
two percent so do not miss out on the
bonus offers you can select the third or
fourth option within six months or more
than 600 now
awesome I'll just give five seconds more
for this poll because I can see folks
have already basically shared when they
do do the plan to enroll
and I can see from the Q a part that
basically we have answered most of the
questions from the Q a as well and uh I
think we were getting a lot of messages
it was pretty engaging on the chart so
I'll just close this poll in five
seconds so five four three two one let
me quickly end the course thank you so
much for sharing uh so uh the Q a part
as I said that I think we have taken uh
most of the questions uh about the
presentation I think is it possible to
share the presentation I'm so sorry we
don't share the presentation but the
recording of This webinar will be
getting a post webinar over meal I've
also shared the live YouTube link as
well and also the YouTube channel where
you can find such other webinars past
recordings there we upload it on the
videos in the live section and I think
uh we have answered most of the
questions here so we are towards the end
of the session now so uh before we end
this session I would love to know that
do you need an assistance towards
enrollment into this program for folks
who have shared their interests and also
have let us know that when do you plan
to enroll so do you need an assistance
into the enrollment with program so
please do let us know in this quick poll
here you see on your screen
I do have a quick uh basically just a
quick survey question for you uh towards
the end of the session I'll just share
that once we are done with this poll and
I just want to say to Dr purushottam
thank you so much for taking out time
the extra time and uh I can see that
passion while you were explaining it uh
when you ask me like do you want me to
continue I was like the audience wants
it like they decide if they want to see
it or not and I saw that basically
engagement from the audience as well
they were still there uh so uh would you
like to see something before we end the
session yeah so thanks a lot actually
see I mean I'm really uh thankful to you
you allowed me to continue guys and to
Russia to you also right okay uh so it
was great uh being here guys and it was
great to share uh some knowledge with
you hope I have given you something good
here for your time that you have spent
with us right so um hope to see you
there in the program and thanks a lot
for joining in thanks Russia yeah that's
it from my end all the best for your
careers
thank you thank you thank you everyone
uh I just have a quick survey for you
folks we would love to know uh basically
what kind of webinars would you want to
see uh from Simply learn so what topics
or areas of Interest would you like to
see covered in future webinars this is a
multiple choice question poll we have a
lot of options here as you can see you
can select multiple options uh this will
give us understanding if you would like
to see these categories of webinars in
the upcoming months and simply learn
similar to the project demo one the
project demo plus program preview one
which we have done with Dr purushottam
uh twice now which is very interesting
from the uh basically the interest we
are seeing from the audience here from
the folks you're getting to learn
something new getting an idea basically
what program covers right like how how
do they cover these projects which
basically helps you get a job right so
uh I can see uh folks have started
sharing what exactly they want to see so
I would love to know basically what do
you want to see so we can bring bring
that for you in the webinars
okay I can see a huge uh vote towards
one option particularly which is not
surprising uh considering the project
demo which we have covered today so the
interesting what's the project termos
fine I'll give five seconds more for a
few of the folks who have not shared uh
please do let us know what areas or
topic of areas interest would you like
to see covered in future webinars from
Simply learn
so I just give five seconds more so five
four three two one let me quickly end
the poll okay thank you so much for
sharing uh your suggestions here uh if
uh you can't see the options basically
if you have something else to
contributing in DME here as well or send
me on chart uh I'll look into that and
as we can see the program project demos
have gotten 75 of the votes
uh and uh we can see the second highest
being the basically Trends industry
specific Insight trends that is upcoming
that is upcoming we're doing those in
normal and December for sure we'll be
covering Trend section and I can see the
interview preparation one getting uh
also like 50 of the words and other
other being like short skills I can see
and career advancement strategies thank
you so much thank you so much for
sharing this we'll try to implement this
in the upcoming webinars by simply learn
thank you so much thank you thank you
I'll be ending the session now I can see
Anusha thank you thank you for sharing
your screen thank you for helping us out
we usually don't do that in webinars but
thank you so much for helping us out and
uh great audience interaction uh we
would love to see you Dr in the upcoming
webinars I think we have planned
something uh I think special in the next
month as well you will get to see doctor
in another project demo we'll be
covering that from the program so thank
you so much folks have a good evening
good night good morning
thank you thank you thank you
you